well welcome everyone today we'll be
discussing uh um aws social architect
access identity and access management in
aws also known as the i am itself so
let's jump straight in and let's start
the session today we'll be discussing uh
a follow uh following uh features of a
we'll be discussing what are the key
features of iron we'll be discussing aws
policies that are included and you can
create we'll be discussing what is iws
user and what kind of permissions we can
assign we will be discussing ion groups
we'll be discussing ion roles as well as
the best practices that we can use
uh when using obviously i am as a
service itself
so let me just erase that and jump
straight onto the overview slide itself
um so key features of the items which is
the identity and access management are
it's a shared access to your account
which means that you can create multiple
users
that will have access to the whole aws
account you can have a granule
permissions as we kind of mentioned
before which means not f1 must be an
admin or in theory should be an admin uh
you can have secure access to aws
resources which means um you can
only enable users to access whatever you
think it is and necessary for them to
access because the
uh has the secure access uh
point here you're gonna have identity
federation which we're gonna be
discussing of different ways of
accessing this and linking this to your
on-prem systems we will be discussing
also multi-functional multi-factor
authentication also known as mfa so
those little forms and code devices that
you can
use uh as a secondary
authentication method we'll be
discussing password policy what kind of
policies we can have and what are the
default ones we'll be also discussing
payment card industry also known as a
pci as well as data security standards
and bss compliance which is important
especially when you're trying to run an
online sales or online stores and you're
taking some sort of payment through your
um
through your system and that's exactly
what we will be mentioning as well as
well as identity information for
assurance which is basically um
what are the minimum requirements from
maybe different vendors to to to
actually approve aws from security
perspectives so that's pretty much what
we'll be discussing i would like to jump
straight into it
and start maybe with shared access so
basically you have a right to grant
permission to users to access and use
resources in your aws account and that's
important
and you don't have to share your own
password with them which means as long
as your admin which pretty much by
default when you create accounts you are
unroot uh you can then create yourself a
admin account and then through this
admin account you can basically uh
create different users and allocate them
with the different permissions and you
can you can then go a little bit further
you can allocate specific users or
specific user in this case to have
access for example to ec2 and the same
user can have access to s3 bucket but
guess what maybe there's a user in your
organization that only has access to s3
but not obviously to uh ec2 which you
can still do basically you can you can
run permissions to every single user or
even a group to any resource you can
think of
or even specific features of each single
resource that you can think of it's
extremely extremely granule it's
extremely powerful and you can really
have full control over that um
so basically that that's what the shirt
access is
i'll jump straight into the second slide
the granule permissions what it is what
it means and how it works well granular
permission allows different permissions
to various users to manage their access
to aws such as user access to specific
services specific permissions for
actions or specific access to resources
now when we're talking granulo
we actually mean that we can dedicate
each user with only
permissions we want them to have so
imagine i want maybe someone to be able
to access my console and only see my
instances so basically read only
instances but not necessarily change
anything they don't have access to
change a name of it they don't have
access to access the instance itself
they don't have access to pretty much
anything they can just see the instances
and reason why we would do that
sometimes is because when you have audit
in your company and somebody else
requests access to your systems you will
have those situations that will come and
say hey i want to access resistance and
you say well that's great i can give you
access because my boss asked me to but
i'm not going to give you uh rights to
change anything because you don't need
them because it's a production system
hence i'm only going gonna give you
read-only access which means that
they cannot perform anything of only
what you gave them in this case
obviously uh access to read-only
instances um and that's it they cannot
do anything else
so that's basically how granular can go
the same applies to s3 the same applies
to pretty much every single thing you
can think of in aws itself so i'm going
to jump straight to the next one
secure access secure
uh securely uh uh allocate credentials
that applications on ec2 um require to
access your aws resources what it means
is that you can basically
have an application running on your aws
account and the particular application
requires access to resources sitting on
the same account like s3 bucket or maybe
even a database storage so what happens
is instead of um
you granting the
the user permission you will actually
grant application a permission you can
do this via the i am and we will discuss
this in a few seconds there is a
difference between granting permissions
to a user and granting a role which is
exactly application itself and imagine
the application itself must access s3
because it contains maybe some sort of
web server file or a bunch of files like
css or images and it must obtain those
so what we will do is we'll basically uh
create a new ion policy saying hey i
want that instance to be able to access
my
s3 bucket and this particular bucket
that we we want
in order to work correctly and that's
the minimum amount of permissions that
the application itself needs in order to
work and we can do that we don't need to
grant all of the permissions to
everything uh we only can grant whatever
it's needed
i have questions here straight away um
volume means it's related to s3 buckets
uh yes it is although in the previous
slide i believe that we discussed
um
so let me just go back volume in this
case is actually
an ebs volume uh so that's a basically
network trial that you attach to your
instance itself uh but
the volume itself will have separate
permissions and you can grant
permissions to instance or volume on
both in the same time so that's the
granule
concept in this case
so
what is identity federation identity
federation allows users with external
accounts to get temporary access to your
abs resources well what it is and what
it means guess what very common scenario
you have active director in your in your
office or maybe in your data center and
instead of creating maybe hundreds of
new users via the i am console what you
can do is you can extend your active
directory using the i am via the
federated
identity federation and all of those
users from your active directory that
you
specify will have access to your aws
resources and it can be easily done and
you don't need to recreate all those
users and better yet you don't need to
manage them from few different places as
long as you manage your ad in the in the
you know very good and uptime way that
means that all the users on your id will
be exactly valid on aws itself um
i see here another question uh but it
was uh i was told earlier that instances
cannot be attached to the s3 directly
box can be accessed but can access ebs
volumes well that's kind of correct uh
by default evs volume is the
network drive that you can attach to
your instance itself
s3 on the other hand cannot be attached
just like that
easily what you need to do is install
additional package that will allow you
to basically mount s3 onto your uh
instance or on top of your system and
then you'll be able to access your um
basically s3 bucket you can actually
access this via the cli which is the
command line interface um
and you can request all the files if you
need to but remember that s3 itself has
a disadvantage because it's not a
a a root device which means the data
cannot be indexed so every single time
you want to uh list what is inside of
the bucket you need to wait a few
seconds or even few minutes depending on
how many files you have in there for the
list of files to be generated from the
bucket itself and that's the
disadvantage so i wouldn't recommend
mounting s3 directly um
just when you use it but what you can do
is you can actually access via cli and
fetch specific files when you need them
and that's achievable
um
um also i have another question here
from ravi babu um as we have a family of
easy instances which instance um a
specific user can create a policy it
doesn't matter the the iron policy
is not is agnostic to uh ec2 itself it's
basically uh it's a list of users that
is allowed to access the whole account
it doesn't matter um what
instance type you have
once you created users on your iam then
this particular user will be able to
create any instance type you want so
that's basically how you think of it
think of i am as a active directory in
your office
it doesn't really matter if if if user
exists on it or no
it means that the resources that you
have within your company are independent
so the access to them is one thing but
the resources in your company are the
second so that's how it works um
another question from chandra here when
we say extend our active directory how
we will do how we
will do by creating another replica
domain another
in aws well there is a very good
tutorial on that i can uh share the link
with you on that uh it's pretty much
it's pretty straight simple all you will
need to do is you will need to create a
forex trust on your ad level and
basically expand this forex trust onto
the aws and then you will generate
basically a
a single file that you're gonna close to
um aws into identity federation and with
this particular file every single time
that you're gonna go to your
uh single sign-on page uh you'll be able
to be redirected straight into aws and
the credentials will be matched with
your user and this way you will be
authenticated so basically it's like
this but i will send you the details by
the end of the session today so remind
me at the end of it if it's okay with
you
um
i can see
a few more questions um
can you change permissions and roles
programmatically instead of
in the iem console yes
yes we can you'll be able to change the
permissions based on either console or
cli which means uh if you remember from
our one of the first sessions uh
basically what a console is is a nice
web interface which is actually using
cli underneath which means every single
action you generate in the console is
actually
converting this into cli and you're
sending commands anyway it's just a
pretty wrapper interface in front of it
so it's
easier to use but yes you have every
single command that you can execute in
the in the in the in the console you can
actually perform in the cli itself
um
so there you go um
i have i have actually thousand lots of
questions you know what i would say like
this
um
maybe if we have all those questions
regarding like very detailed ones
regarding like can we maybe uh is it aws
32 service the same as msad service and
also we have a unix open ldap and all of
those questions which are very very
valid and technical i would want those
questions to be maybe in a q a at the
end which we'll have lots of time to
discuss so let's go through maybe a few
few more slides and
uh we're going to be doing lots of demos
as well and at the end we're just going
to go through that i would think that's
that's the best way forward for us so as
i said you have different routes of uh
authenticating you can even use facebook
if you want or you can have you have a
google account to access the same way
depending how your organization is
actually authenticating against your
systems most of the time is actually
active directory because that's
obviously the most common and then you
will be able to do that but remember
it doesn't mean that you need to use any
of them it's an option but there's no
need because most of the time when you
even have an organization maybe like 10
20 000 people working in it guess what
not 20 000 people will be accessing your
aws in fact i can bet maybe even five to
ten people be accessing the aws out of
twenty thousand which means effort
needed for uh implementing active
directory itself
um might not be worth doing that it
might be easier to just create a few
users directly in the i am account and
manage this like that and it
might be much quicker for you to do it
so think about it um rather than
complicate your life always remember
keep it simple keep it easy
as i said before
so next one
identity information
well in here you can log monitor and
track what users are doing with your
resources remember when we mentioned
this before when you when you enable
cloudtrail um which we discussed
probably on lesson number two um you'll
be able to log every single activity
from every single user that actually
interacts with the whole account and
that's a big benefit for you what it
means you will have full audit and
history of everything that is happening
and how it works is aws called trail
creates a log files for every single
account and uploads this to s3 bucket
specified and then you can basically
fetch those files from there from the s3
bucket and basically pass them or read
them because they're in a clear text
file which means you have a full
visibility of what's going on and maybe
what happened in in case something broke
so you can trace back and see exactly
what is wrong
so
going sorry about that let me just
disable this
now also we will be discussing a little
bit more about pci dss compliance what
it is and why why do we use it well
payment card industry which is a pci and
data security standards compliant is
used for example when you're taking
credit card payments on the websites for
online stores it's very common and you
must be pci compliant uh and you must
obtain certification to do that and we
will look a little bit more into this in
the next few slides
now
another benefit of using the i am itself
is that you have a multi-factor
authentication what it means is not only
you have to provide the password itself
but also you need to provide a second
method of the authorization for the
users uh in order for them to be able to
access it how it works is well you have
a bunch of users and all those users are
using the uh they want to use console so
they basically get a
a link to the i am
console itself where they put your their
username and password as a standard but
also
they provide a code from an mfa device
it can be either a physical one like a
little token or it can be actually
software installed on your phone
something like a google authenticator
that generates password every let's say
60 seconds and
when user is logging they must provide
the most up-to-date code in order to
authenticate in here and it's a very
common uh scenario that
people can
by default lots of people actually
enable this because it improves security
of the account why because lots of
people send their own username and
passwords uh maybe via the email maybe
they save this on their computer guess
what the computer got hacked or
something actually went through all
their files the the username and
password leaked and somebody is for
example a full admin of of your account
guess what this username and password
can be used by hackers or anyone else
out there to access the account and you
have no idea about it but if you have an
mfa device then every 60 seconds hacker
actually must provide when they want to
log in
must provide this particular code which
is randomly generated and allocated to
this particular user which means it's
next to impossible even if you have
username and password to actually access
resources which i would highly encourage
you to do
um
i have another question here while
auditing how much how much uh how much
does does that affect the performance
this is because in oracle similar trail
is there
and if we enable uh does it give any
performance issues no it doesn't um
imagine that
aws cloud trail is working in parallel
um on on the aws itself and it doesn't
slow down any of your systems um
everything is logged anyway by aws
behind the scene it's just when it's
disabled you don't have access to this
um when you enable this it actually
outputs the data into the bucket itself
so there is no performance degradation
um
so there you go i have another question
taranjit can we assume rsa token
authentication also
like mfa device yes it's exactly the
same it's exactly the same principle um
it's uh you can actually access on the
aws website uh
the page about mfa authentication and
what kind of levels are are provided
there and you can see if your uh maybe
mfa or rsa tokens are actually on the
supported list and if they are you can
actually use it
so there you go that's what what you
would do
another thing that i am actually
provides you is a
a password policy now what it is and how
we use it guess what
by default when you when you create
account it's pretty okay it's i wouldn't
say it's it's strict but it's okay the
minimum amount of uh
characters allowed is six which is
obviously better than uh
random four or five that is allowed on
many other systems by default uh you can
then enable different features like
require at least one uppercase require
at least uh
you know one letter one number and you
can basically even enable something like
enable password expiration which is
actually very good and then you can put
after how many days and all of those uh
little features that you you have will
enable you to secure your access to the
aws account
in a in a much simpler and much more
secure way why well guess what aws
itself is not a physical data center
that you can just basically go in and
like maybe your on-prem systems or
servers
where they are guided by let's say maybe
this tv maybe you have obviously
locked the door maybe you have maybe
guards or anything else you might have
in the place
aws itself is a basically cloud
service which is which is which doesn't
exist as a premise you have you have no
access there which means all access you
can have is only virtual hands to the
internet so make sure you actually
tighten all those policies and maybe
align them with your company which means
that you don't use simple puzzles like
one two three four five or maybe
password this password so it can be
broken and your account will be taken
over by someone um and be used for wrong
or they can spin up lots of resources
and you will pay for this so make sure
you
you you understand that and you also go
through
this by default
now we're going to describe a few i am
policies
and i am policy is
and then we're gonna say what it is it's
a document that defines one or more
permissions
it's attached to a user group or role
it's written in javascript object
notation which is basically an adjacent
format it's selected from pre-defined
aws list of policies or you can create
your own policy
yeah so basically that's it when you
create a new policy it's basically a
simple um let's say text file in the
json format and you can specify all the
rules and permissions in there it can be
as simple as i only allow this
particular user to access a single
resource or allow user to access
everything and we'll be looking into
this in a second
so adobe's itself has
many i would say in in fact loads of
predefined policies uh which will allow
you to define granular access to your
aws resources in fact when i started i
basically only use aws predefined
policies it was more than i needed and
they were pretty much awesome what you
can think is in a filter window here you
can um
you can basically type anything you want
like s3 for example or or you can type
maybe ec2 or or rds and you'll see all
the policies that aws things that you
might use and they predefine them by
default and they have lots of policies
they have for example policies sfo
administrator access which quite likely
one or two people in your company should
have in order to create other users uh
you might have amazon s3 full access
which means a user will be able to
access all the s3 buckets uh read and
write but no other resources you can
have lots of other ones like apis you
can have
every single service will have its own
permissions um obviously like
administrator for example will have
access pretty much all access to all
services so make sure you understand
that but we'll actually
uh talk about it and as i said there are
over 200 predefined policies in fact
there are the number is growing more and
more because ada is introducing more
services and every single service will
have multiple policies so it's more than
200 right now but it's a huge number
i have a question from challenge why aws
is using a json for writing policy
documents it's actually a very good
question nobody really knows i think the
reason why they went with json is
because they wanted to unify their uh
their systems and pretty much everything
else in aws will use the json as a
standard so cloud formation for example
um and pretty much anything else we use
json so that's pretty much what they
went with they thought it's it's it's
it's clean it's it's easy which in some
cases it might not as you might uh as
you probably already know because asking
this question it might be confusing a
little bit here and there and it's a
massive file as well
it's what they went and what they have
so i think we need to just adjust to
that um
i have another question here from robin
babu about the mfa so mfa means
different users
access the same aws account or how is uh
how is it can you explore more on the
same
nfa means that when user is logging into
the account um and they provide user in
the password
on top of that it will ask them for mfa
code which means that when you have a
token in your hand or even application
running on your phone something like a
google authenticator for example it will
generate a code run those six digits
that you must basically enter while
you're logging in and that code is
matched with your account
and if it matches basically which
obviously does because you just typed it
it allows you to log in but this code
changes every 60 seconds which means if
you didn't put your code within 60
seconds the other code expires which
means nobody can use it uh the old code
you need to specify the new one this way
aws knows that when you're logging in
it's you it's not someone else who took
your uh identity because they don't have
msa in their hand so that's exactly what
it is
so
skipping a little bit more
and we're going to be discussing a
little bit more about administrator and
access policy what it is is
administrative active policy provides
full access to all to all aws services
and resources and this is important you
need to remember that um if you start
granting an internet of access to
everyone
and they will have full right to
basically create new stuff and also
delete every single existing um resource
that you ever created they don't have
any restriction which is a little bit
scary because if someone doesn't know
how this aws and you want them too much
permissions they can simply break the
whole account they don't have right to
terminate the whole account because that
you can only do with a root account but
if you have production servers or any
resources or even uploaded lots of files
into the s3 for backup purposes and
someone actually
went there and read it by mistake well
guess what it's not very pretty and i
can give you a very good case from a
real life what happened we basically i
worked for this company where um admin
didn't have any clue of what kind of
permissions to assign and he pretty much
gave everyone a full admin um account
and there was this one user let's call
him
a bulb just just because we can
and bob um it was okay he knew how to
use aws more or less but bob i wanted to
use an application that you know from
the internet uh it was a free
application to browse the s3 and it was
free and it was okay and the application
itself asked him to provide credentials
to access
aws s3 itself and so he did but the
problem with application was that
application went a little bit wonky and
uh crashed at some stage and what
happened is when he was browsing for for
a specific bucket what he didn't know is
the application actually crashed and
started deleting all the files and
sending this command to aws and because
he had a full write on the whole account
he basically wiped out the whole content
of a s3 bucket and funny enough that was
a production bucket and he caused lots
of issues and damage to the company
without even knowing about it so it's
not always about the user sometimes it's
about the applications that you use so
make sure that when you give someone
permissions they don't have destructive
permissions like a full admin to destroy
everything else out there
um so i have another question here
should the new user be created using
root account or the admin user it's a
very good question no i would say like
this when you create a new account you
only have a root account
basically with a good account create
yourself an admin account that is
actually towards you
and on this moment onwards never ever
use root account obviously i would
advise to secure root account with the
mfa some sort of so nobody can take
those credentials even if you saw them
maybe copied in the file maybe this file
got leaked or
something happened so make sure you have
mfl on the root account and then from
this moment onwards use only your own
for admin account to create other people
why we will do that is because if for
example we are logging activity with a
cloudtrail explanation before and
everyone uses root well you cannot know
who actually is accessing because
everyone is called roots so you don't
know who blocks up or who access stuff
so i would say create dedicated user and
with a dedicated user then create other
users so there you go so basically
that's the little uh
tip
for you guys
now there is another one called amazon
ec24 access policy what it will allow
you is not only access ec2 itself but
also a few other services like uh load
balancer amazon cloud watch and also
auto scaling and pretty much all those
services if you think about it they're
kind of separate but they're actually
linked when you're thinking about it
because in order for you to have a full
access to ec2 there are subsystems that
are integrated and work in parallel
together in order for this to work so
when you have amazon ec2 well sometimes
you use also eob which is a part of ec2
but by by default a load balancer has
its own permissions and policies the
same applies to cloud watch which
obviously shows you all the statistics
and and and performance charts as well
as auto scaling which allows you to spin
up more instances uh automatically so in
amazon ec2 for access policy you will
have access to all four by default which
is very handy sometimes so
i will skip a little bit forward
another type of the policy itself what
we have is amazon s3
uh
really only access it's a very very
common uh policy that we use because it
only allows read only from a specific uh
uh
service called s3 now it's it's good
because it doesn't allow access anywhere
else however you need to remember that
this user will have access to every
single bucket on s3 which sometimes can
be dangerous because if you think about
it if you have multiple buckets and some
of those buckets might contain
information like a secret to a company
that may be sensitive to a market or
maybe some stuff
you know your clients data that maybe
shouldn't be accessed by anyone if you
will grant someone uh s3 really on the
access that means they will have access
to the same bucket but in the ring mode
only yes they cannot delete stuff they
cannot
override stuff because they have only uh
with only access but they can still
access this so maybe it's important to
remember
to
not do that um
when you setting it up
so i have question here um
i see a question from ravi babu what is
the difference between admin user and
the normal user in terms of roles it's
good question admin user itself will
have access to
every single service and will have
access it's basically like a route
without being able to terminate the
account which means you have access to
everything
read write change and modify delete
anything you can think of
and the normal user
you will be able to allocate normal user
with only specific rights to specific
services if you for example use this one
as a s3 read only you will only be able
to access a single s3 bucket in the
read-on-only mode so that's important to
remember
so
i have another question from package
it's can we restrict the access to
multiple sv uh do we need to create a
new policy that this kind of access well
yes we can what you can do is you can
create a single policy that on the
bucket saying that uh the only access to
this bucket
is from a depth of care group or from
this particular user and every other
user is restricted by default and what
happens is even if someone has read only
access that means that if you locked it
with your other permission it means that
the lock permission will be more
important than access everything and
this way you can restrict access to the
bucket itself and only allow specific
user or group of users or maybe systems
to access that
um
so another question from chandra is by
default we have we will have only one s3
bucket
um actually by default you don't have
any buckets created on the account i i
think what what happens is you need to
create a s3 bucket by yourself um and
you will be going through this uh in a
probably
next session s3 is there as well as rds
so we will be able to discuss that by
default there are no buckets uh
available to you so that's um
another question from genre can we
create multiple s3 buckets yes yes we
can you can have as many buckets as you
want and they must be unique and the
names of the buckets must be actually
unique worldwide which means if you're
going to create a bracket something like
maybe
upload
or maybe my file or my files or my
folder quite likely someone already used
it um
which means that you cannot create this
so they might be unique the good idea if
you think about it is to give some sort
of prefix to it like maybe name of your
company and dash a folder that maybe you
think of and that way you can be sure
that nobody else is using that
and
i can see more questions about s3 and i
would say i'm actually more than happy
to answer all those questions about s3
but i would say let's wait up until we
reach the s3 itself and then we'll be
discussing all the policies regarding
the s3 itself and quite likely we'll
have also a demo today that i'll be able
to show you a few things
and tricks about it so basically what is
json and how we use it json is a very um
interesting uh file format um that
defines all the policies and is using a
java open object notation which is also
known as the json itself this is in
policy-wide information so version date
so when the policy was created and it is
also using multiple layers of
of
of basically order so in this case we
have a version and then in the statement
we open the bracket and then we put what
kind of statements we have so we have
effect allow action s3 list buckets and
resource and you specify which bucket
you want someone to access what happens
here is we allowed
access to list all the buckets pretty
much this bucket and we allow but
specific this policy to only list what
is inside example underscore bucket and
that's pretty much it the single policy
will allow a single user if you
obviously allocate this um this this
point is the user to only list what is
inside of this particular bucket and
that's it
it's simple and it can
um do this i have request to repeat this
absolutely fine so
the effect uh in this case is allow
which means that we are allowing access
to specific resource action is s3 which
specifies access to the s3 and then
action on the s3 itself is the list
bucket which means basically we list a
content of what is inside now resource
which means what do you want access is
basically a bucket name which is in this
case we use example underscore bucket
and will allow
to
show to the user so basically list all
the content of this bucket itself so i
hope that that's that um
uh that's understandable i have a
question from challenge what is on on is
basically it's a it's basically network
extension that you need to specify and
it's a format that aws uh basically
requests you to do is basically address
to aws of what resource you need to use
so on is basically like address aws is a
service s3 is a component of the service
and then example bucket is the resource
that you want to access
um
i see another question
what is the difference between a list
bucket and example bucket well okay
i it's the difference is that a list
bucket itself
in here
it's an action which means what kind of
action can be performed
on
that bucket
think of it as
in windows for example you have a folder
and the folder you can allocate actions
like you can read
you can write
and then you can read plus write right
so
action is basically what can happen so
read write uh read write and also lists
because you can restrict users from
seeing what is inside
but resource itself is the name of the
folder so if this folder is called
example
like let's say underscore packet
that's exactly what it is that's the
folder that we want to access and that
is the permission that we want to
grant
i have a question from chargeet what the
three columns mean in here um basically
that's a format that aws itself um
requests from you in order for uh for
the resources to be specified so
basically you're gonna see pretty much
every single time when you use any i i
json policies that that particular
format so on column aws column and then
resource and then three dots is used all
the time and that's the format that aws
allows you to specify
when you're creating policies now if you
make a mistake in this don't worry
because you have so called a policy
validator which is a big button before
you actually submit that and that will
allow you to validate if your policy is
valid and you didn't make any mistakes
and trust me with so many characters in
here you can sometimes you forget maybe
about a single dot maybe you forget to
close the bracket and when you validate
that it will basically show you straight
away
from challenges sometimes i see content
between those three columns sometimes
you will because certain uh certain
services will actually have uh
intermediate uh resources in between s3
is a simple service that is basically
just the name of the bucket there is
nothing between and that's it so if s3
has only a bucket
name itself that's why it's only three
dots three columns and nothing between
we will see more uh with probably more
examples here in in the next slide but
let's move on and hopefully we'll get to
this uh soon as well
so what we're going to do is we're going
to create an item policy and we're going
to we will demonstrate how to do this
what i will do now i will basically go
to my aws lab and feel free to do this
in the same time if you want or if you
don't you can just watch how we do this
in order to do that we will go basically
to services and under services under
security identity and compliance will go
to i am
once we are in the i am i have funny
enough i have
very restricted access
in the policies
get started
create a policy
now when we click a button create a
policy what can happen is um it will
allow you to um
sorry one second
yes
it will actually allow you to do a few
things you can copy an existing uh
policy from what we've seen before the
database specified you can generate
generate policy from the police
generator which has pretty much every
single policy out there and you can also
create your own in which case quite
likely you google something and you just
want to copy and paste it what i will do
is i will basically create an existing
policy and just rename it for the sake
of the exercise
[Music]
unfortunately for some reason my user
doesn't have a right to do that which is
interesting enough um
let me do it a little bit differently in
this case
what i will do
um
[Music]
i will log into
to a different account
so what we're going to do is we're going
to go to iron
and in the i am you basically go to the
policies in policies we're going to
create a new policy
and in here
um we'll be able to copy an existing
policy from aws
now we can basically search as i said
before there are quite a few and this is
very very long over 200 and what will
help is basically to
basically search in the filter so what
i'm interested is s3 what i want is and
maybe read only access
and there you go that's our basically
policy so just to describe this policy
is is as follows what we have is
basically the policy version which
basically in aws itself doesn't change
it's always the same number and then we
have a statement in statement we
actually allow
and in actions to get
star and list star which means to get
all the content and list all the content
from the resource and in this case it's
a star which means that the users will
be able to a list of what is inside of
the bucket itself as well as download it
um so basically get it and the resource
star in this case means that users will
be able to get
access to pretty much everything
on a whole account so that's important
if you use a star in the resource that
means access to pretty much every other
bucket so what i want to do is i'm not
gonna change this policy but what i will
do is i will basically create my own
policy i will call it demo
um s3 read
only
and the good idea is not to use spaces
and description you can put whatever you
want i will just put some random stuff
because it doesn't really matter to me
but it'll be good to describe in the
description because if somebody is else
using this um
policy on your account that will quickly
be able to read it and understand why so
when we create this policy uh you can
see that in here it said the policy name
must contain uh only uh
the policy name must contain only
alphanumeric characters and uh following
which means
um
did i actually put a space yeah i put a
space a white space at the end and
probably that's why it didn't work now
before i actually create the policy you
can see here that we have a
validate policy this is exactly the
policy validator that i mentioned before
so what happens is before i save it i
can validate it and suddenly in here in
the green field you can see the policy
is valid that means that it was just
parsed and it's exactly okay it will
work so
what i do now is i basically create a
policy
and if i'm going to go to
s3 in here you can see that suddenly we
have a new demo s3 read only policy and
the one
that we just created doesn't have any
logo here which means it's not an aws
policy itself it's ours and then with
this policy you can then attach it
anywhere else you want so there you go
this is how we create it and this is how
we how we do it so i will switch back to
the the slides so we can actually go a
little bit more and
further
so what it is users are defined as a
people or systems that use aws resources
and basically this is what we define as
a imuser it can be as simple as a single
person like admin it can be an end user
that actually accesses the systems uh
occasionally or it can even be a system
itself that is defined as a user that is
granted permissions to access specific
resources um from equities itself and
that's what it is
so security credentials
aws
provides numerous ways to provide secure
user access to your aws resources
what it is and what happens email
email address and password
there are created when you sign up to a
use aws there are used to send in to aws
web pages and exactly this is what it is
basically you specify email address in
the password and you can use those two
in order to access the console itself
let me just minimize this for one second
so i can see exactly what we're talking
about
now
i am user name and the password and they
allow multiple individuals or
applications to access your agendas
account individuals use their usernames
and the passwords to sign in so what it
is is it's not an email address that is
assigned to a single person it's a
basically a username that is not an
email and then you use the combination
of the random user as well as password
in order to provide multiple individuals
applications or systems to to basically
authenticate the games and when would
we use it is well you have a situation
you have let's say maybe two web servers
that running in parallel or maybe even
three if you want and they need access
to let's say s3 because they need a
specific file in order to function uh
well guess what you'll create a single i
am user for that you basically grant all
those systems a single item user and the
user will be allocated with the same
permission access s3 itself so all those
three servers maybe even you have
hundreds of servers after that we'll use
the same permissions and that's exactly
what it is
what we also have is a multi-factor
authentication which is exactly mfa that
we discussed with that you will be able
uh it's not enabled by default this is
what i need to stress you need to enable
that and then users are prompted to use
the username and the password and in
addition then we need to use
authentication code from the mfa device
in order to be able to access database
console resources
so this is what it is another type of
security credentials is basically access
key and the access key itself consists
of a key and a secret key and that's a
basically pair that you always use
together and that
is uh used when you're trying to access
programmatic uh
requests which means basically when
you're using command line interface so
you're trying to maybe code any
application
access to specific resources you're
trying to access uh maybe s3 or or
create maybe some servers because you
can and you'll use access keys because
that's how you connect with the cli
itself
another type is a keeper keeper
basically is uh is a public and private
key that you can generate either via the
aws or you can already have already
existing ones in your environment now um
keepers are very very popular in the
linux environment and this is pretty
much how most of the people authenticate
to their systems they don't tend to use
them in the passwords what they do is
they create a single keeper on their own
uh device so maybe your own out of a
computer and then you distribute the the
uh the part of the key to the systems
that you need to access and with your
master key then you can access every
other system because it matches your uh
shirt key that you actually distribute
against the system so this is exactly
what it is and it also allows you to
access aws if you want to if you if you
for example have already keeper you can
use this to use um
on all database resources using this
method so this is what it is
and let's go a little bit further
now we have a situation if you were the
aws administrator of your company which
of the following options should you use
to grant user access to the account
and then basically
imagine
you have um
let me just sorry um
stay with me just one second
now
and you will basically uh have
situations like um
sorry i have one question here can i
create a web server um
as aws user
um
no
no you can't uh what you need to do in
this case you will need to create a user
uh that has
permissions to access some resources and
this user you will be able to allocate
the server as for example a row which
we'll be discussing in the next few
slides and that will basically grant
your web server access to aws resources
so this is how it is
so basically and in this chart we have a
bunch of users that are exposed to aws
itself and all those users can either uh
use in situation a a single user
um
or they can use uh ion itself as a
different users now advantage of that
and disadvantages as follows yes in this
case all you need to do is create a
single user that you share between all
the uh colleagues
or within your company and pretty much
you know that whoever logs in with this
user has always the same rights because
it's a single user with a single right
which is great but in this case you
create multiple users and here
and that authenticate against the
impolicy itself what happens here you
will need to create a multiple users in
this case let's say 3d and all those
users will be logging uh to the console
the same way but what's the difference
between those two well guess what if you
have all the users like in the situation
here connecting by a single user you
cannot really track who is doing what
because everyone logs in as the same
user and in your even logs everything
seems to be the same
well in here you can have a full view
and audit of every single user accessing
your uh systems so it would be in your
advantage to create a multiple different
users within multiple permissions
because not everyone will be equal and
the same in your company so that's the
advantage it will be a little bit more
work because you need to create few more
users but trust me long term you're
gonna be thankful because if someone
breaks something you'll be able to know
what happened and why so that's the
situation here
so we're gonna be creating i am user
itself and we're gonna demonstrate how
to do it so i'm gonna switch to my
account um basically i know that the
the
simpson account is actually locked for
that so i will use my own so just watch
if you can we're gonna go to users
itself and i'm gonna create a new user
well i'm going to create a user called
demo
user
and pretty much what i wanted to do and
in a aws resource type i want this user
to be able to access
maybe either a console
or maybe they want to have a pro pro a
programmatic access but what it means
when i click the programmatic it means
that i want the user to be able to
access database api cli and sdk for
maybe development tools which means they
will only have access via the command
line and it will generate the key for
them and the secret well this option
here database management console access
which means they will be able to use
their username and the password which
can either be auto generated here or you
can use a custom password which
obviously must match your policy itself
uh in order for them to uh access the
console itself now you can select both
if you want if someone wants to access
the console and use the key as well for
specific application which is fully
available what i want to do in this case
is i want maybe to create just the the
access to the console and i'm going to
auto generate the password itself
so you can also see that once you auto
join the password here you have option
require password reset it stick by
default which means that the password
once a user once logged in using this
auto generated password will need to
change the password itself so what i
would do is basically i will create it
you can see that now the second type is
set permissions for a demo user that
we're just trying to access well guess
what in this case what we can do is
maybe um
maybe we want to use we can actually
have a groups we can have uh
you can copy permissions from existing
user as well as you can attach existing
policies directly well guess what we
just created a policy called demo s3
user here but we can actually filter
this people
demo you can see the single possible
created uh with this description which
is not very descriptive but we did we
can take that and we can go next
that's where we review it so basically
everything is in order and then we
create a user what happens now is the
user was created and you can actually
see here
that the demo user was created
himself and we have a password here and
we have an email
login instructions well it's a very very
good thing and i would i highly uh
encourage you to show the password
because once you
go away from here from this page while
you create one you cannot ever see the
password you can reset it but you will
not be able to see it also i would
advise you uh to maybe keep the if you
want to keep the password for the future
use what you can do is you can click on
the button here called download.csv and
that will download an excel format file
with the username and the password
itself and you can keep this for your
records maybe on your own systems so
what i can do is i can maybe download
this first of all so i can download it i
can show this in a second and i can show
the password so it was auto generated
it's a bunch of random characters as you
can see
so i can also send email it will ask me
uh you know what system do i want to use
i have outlook it will basically put all
the information in the email and we can
send it off but we also generated the
uh the file and i'm gonna show you how
it looks you can see here that the the
user is called demo user the password is
this uh it doesn't have a secret key and
doesn't have a secret access key because
we did not want the programmatic access
and you can see that the access to the
console is via specific link and you can
send the link to the user you can send
them user in the password and they will
be able to authenticate into your
console as this particular user and
that's as simple as this so we just
created a whole user and assigned
permissions it's that simple it probably
is even more simple than creating 80 uh
so active directory user because it's
basically next next next um and that's
pretty much it so it was as simple as
this
so now we're going to go to i am groups
straight away
what is that i am group is basically uh
aws defines aws
a group as a collection of users that
inherit the same set of permissions it's
basically the same as a as a group in an
id so you specify a group you allocate
multiple users to the group and all of
those users within the group
will have
the same permissions because you can
allocate permissions to the group itself
and it's very handy now when we use it
and why we use it
well if you have in this case um maybe
administrator access and you have few
admins your company that must access the
database itself well yes you can you can
grant all of them
i mean write individually as a user but
would be better
to create a single group called admin
group
and basically put all of the admins in
there and allocate the admin group with
the policy with administrator access in
this case you only change this uh policy
once and you affect all the users what
it means is that if for example you want
to update the policy you don't need to
update the policy for all those
withering company and i mean like few is
nice but sometimes you have maybe 20 50
and sometimes even 100 users that you
must update and trust me you don't want
to sit all day long and click on all of
them hence you only change one thing in
the group and all of them will inherit
the same thing so that's very handy and
it's very recommended
so what we would do is most of the time
we'll create different groups for
different kind of people we have we
might have developers and we might have
admin as i just described and in the
developers we have users like mike jane
and ahm and in the admins we have mark
zara and jim and guess what in
developers will have access to slightly
different resources admins will have
access to pretty much everything but
that's good because you don't want
developers which have no knowledge of
aws itself to go log in and start
breaking stuff because they don't
understand how this works and this is
how you would exactly do this so it
would always be recommended to create a
different group so different kind of
users and try to allocate them
across
the whole company in each uh in each
group the good news is that a one user
can be a member of multiple groups what
it means if for example you have a user
called admin and you're granted
information to admins and you grant any
permissions to developers well guess
what
admins have rights to pretty much
everything and developers have
restricted access which means they're
kind of overlap a little bit they they
have pretty much the same rules with
exception with developer is a little bit
restricted but it means it will still
have a full admin right no matter what
uh even if it's part of the developers
that's as simple as this so it's
actually very good
um
so yeah there you go
this is how we do this
so creating a m group so i will show you
how to do it right now
i will go back to the i am
i will go to the groups
and i will go to create a new group
i will call a demo
group
and i'll click next
and basically it asks me to attach the
policy now i can but i don't have to in
this case i will just because i can i
can i can show you how it works i can
basically uh filter this through uh
sorry i made a
demo
and you can see the policy that we
generated you can just click and add
and create and that's it we just created
a demo group with the same permissions
as our user and that was as simple as
maybe three clicks and it took me 10
seconds to do in fact you can do it
maybe in five if you really click quick
so there you go this is how simple it is
so
i am rolls
what are i am roles
well it is very similar to a user
um itself uh eight of these i uh uh i
identities with permission policies that
determine the access available to
identities and i'll i now actually
explain this in a few seconds not
password protected and do not require
access key which you can if you think
it's wait a minute that's actually
unsecured there's no password and
there's not really a protection and
doesn't write keys so why would i want
to use it and also assumed by anyone who
requires them i'll go straight into this
and explain how it works
so basically imagine
you have
um
let's let's go through this like this
roles are used to provide access to
users applications and services that do
not have permissions to use aws
resources well if you think about that
what does it mean
you have maybe a
an application in
in here
and this application itself requires
access to
s3 bucket to get in fact a a photo so
application requires access to the
bucket itself but guess what you don't
want to grant this particular server
and generate the whole
access with the keys with permissions
and everything else just like that
because maybe your application doesn't
support it
you can't just program this new
application you just want it to be able
to use it so what will happen is you
will be able to create a role that
grants access to the photo bucket and
the role itself
will basically launch the instance um
itself and assign this particular role
that's important when you're launching
the instance you'll be able to assign
that particular role to the to the
instance itself
and what happens is this application
once fully running has access
automatically to the bucket itself
without providing any credentials if you
think about it it can be
tricky and scary sometimes because you
think why why would it happen or guess
what applications sometimes must access
specific resources on aws and you don't
want to authenticate every single time
that this application accesses this it's
as simple as if you have a server
somewhere in the office and this server
requires access to your file system at
the end you can actually whitelist the
server saying i need the server to be
able to access it because maybe it's a
backup server or something and it will
not require username it will not prepare
a password it will just allow access but
only to this one machine and this is
exactly what we have so you don't need
to
make your application complex to uh pass
any any keys any any um any credentials
because maybe someone will a hack or
maybe someone will just uh
you know log into your server and they
can actually see all those keys and they
can use this key for themselves uh
somewhere else to access the same
resources and role itself will only
allow one server that you spun out
access to static resource and that's a
beauty of that
i can see a question here this means the
policy is created and granted a group uh
and uh to a group a group is granted to
users or roles uh with the same
permission correct or if i'm wrong um
i don't really understand the the
question uh policy is created
um
okay i understand now so basically uh
how is what about privacy is asking is
the policy itself uh when we create is
basically um
a file that allows you to specify
permissions itself uh so what kind of
access we have and then we can grant
this a policy to a group and we can
assign any number of users the group
itself which means any user underneath
the group itself will have exactly the
same policy as the group was assigned
with so this is how exactly it works
um
i have another question here in this
case uh are we create uh creating a role
to access the s3 bucket alone um yes in
this particular case yes we can in fact
we can create a basically a a role which
has a
permission to access specific bucket or
maybe even specific folder uh folder
under under the bucket and we can say
this particular application
has access to this folder and can access
any let's say
star
jpegs jpeg
jpeg file which means it will be able to
access this without requesting
you know credentials and exchanging any
security information it is still secure
because it's only assigned to a specific
box but that's it
it's actually very good
um
so basically chandra is asking can we
treat i am role as a rbac which is a
role based access control policy uh yes
yes we can it's pretty much the same if
you think about it it's just a little
bit simplified
but it works in the same way so yes we
can
um
can the same thing be done by assigning
policy
yes it can but if you will do that so if
you for example you will in this
particular case you will not use a row
but you will use i am user
um in this case you will need to program
within your application a username and
password or access keys so basically a
long long access which is basically a
key and then a secret which is a bunch
of other things and you need to use api
or any other means to access your
resources and you only need to
authenticate every single time and not
always that's the best and the quickest
way because authentication itself is a
little bit overhead so if your
application requests uh hundreds of
thousands of files every every minute or
so and you need to authenticate on top
of that well it will generate a huge
overhead rather than just permission
straight away which can be actually it's
a
simplification for your application so
you need to worry about authenticating
yourself with a bunch of keys that can
change or anything else you're basically
just writing permission straight away
and what's important basically when
you're granting a role
and i think we have this in the next few
slides um no we don't but i will tell
you this anyway when we're granting a
role
what happens is
a temporary
temporary access is granted for up to
one hour and every hour
access between those two
is actually refreshed so they do use a
bunch of
hidden keys behind it but those are
automatically rotated keys behind the
scene and it's not
with your application is on the aws
level itself so aws takes care of the
whole security and rotates every single
hour a key behind the scene to make sure
that you have constant permission and
that's all it is to you any application
is simplification and it's ease of use
but it's still extremely secure so i
would say majority of the time
when we create uh applications we always
you know use roles rather than uh users
because it's actually much better you
don't have a bunch of keys that people
send around in the emails maybe copy and
paste in the file or keep it maybe even
paste it on like internet somewhere
sometimes and you can find those keys
everywhere and you can use them to
access people's files you don't it's
actually secure because you don't have a
key itself so that's that's how it works
so i'm going to show you how to create a
role right now on the database itself
so we're going to go to roles we have no
roles at the moment i will create one i
will call it a demo
role
i i know i think i think you get a
pattern of what we call things and how
and then you basically have permissions
well um do you want this role to have
aws uh service uh access to the roles
you want this to have um a role to cross
account access which means you can have
an access from one role to a totally
different ecobase account which you can
basically access that different
resources or you can have a role for
identity providers which you can
actually have
logging through amazon facebook and
everything we said before for this
exercise we're going to create basically
a simple easy tool
and we're going to go for our favorite
demo
s3 reader me that we created before
and
create and that's all it is suddenly we
have a role called demerol and this
particular demo role uh
will have exactly the same policy as our
user demo s3 read only
we can see the policy here which is
exactly what we have created before
you can attach new policy if you want to
it and and you'll be able suddenly to
attach this role to a server that you
just created and this server will have
exactly the permissions that are
specified in here which means list all
the resources versus three without using
a single user in the password and that's
great because you can jump on the server
and you can straight away start using it
all to access all the resources
that we just mentioned
um
i have a few more questions here um
can we assign multiple roles to one a
ec2 instance it's actually a good
question i would say uh no you can
assign only a single role to a server
and so but you can assign multiple
policies to each of them and once the
server is up and running you cannot
actually change the role you will need
to create a new one so that's important
to remember
can you show me in a demo that will help
us to understand more
um
can you show me the demo that will help
me understand more i don't understand
the questions can you actually elaborate
a little bit more about that i would
really appreciate and i'll be able to
answer this question i have another one
um oh i have already i have already
shown you this okay sorry um i hope i
answered this by the demo itself um who
says uh
the memory load of the requests for the
web server
i don't understand the questions
could you elaborate a little bit more
about that i'll be able to answer uh
obviously more than happy to um
until then i will answer a few other
questions what is the difference between
a role and the policy well the policy
itself remember is a collection of
permissions uh that we have
and granting a specific resource a role
itself is basically
a role
is basically a
it's a collection of policies that we
can attach to any instance so in this
case we created a a policy called demo
estrogen only
and then attach this policy to a row
called demo roll and that role we can
attach to let's say a server which means
you can attach any number of policies
underneath here
and attach to a role and use it as to
access multiple resources so this is how
it is
so basically what we'll be discussing
right now in the in the slide 53 is how
to uh create an individual ion users
what are the benefits of creating uh
individual users as i kind of mentioned
before it will generate unique
credentials for everyone uh you will
have control of permissions to an on the
individual level it's easier to rotate
the credentials in this way and you
don't have any shared accounts and it's
even easier to identify security
breaches so that's the benefit and
let's go straight into a next slide
you can also when you have a single a
user as we mentioned before
and individual users you'll be able uh
when creating ion policies you can grant
at least privilege that means that users
uh you they can only grant requested you
can only grant them request permissions
which means they have access no nobody
else
nowhere no more
than they need to it's more secure to
start with uh minimum permissions and
then grow over time so if for example
i'm going access to s3
bucket because i need to access data
there well there is no point of view of
granting permissions to everything um
because it's pretty much unsecured which
means that if i have
uh if i have requests in the future hey
i actually need access to s3 and now i
need access to maybe ec2 you can just
add me access to the ec2 at later stage
and this is how it should be done list
is always least amount of privileges
it's always the best way forward it's
easier to grant permissions that revoke
them that's correct it's actually much
easier to grant a smaller permissions
then start blocking so when you access
when you grant permissions uh to pretty
much to some uh someone to everything
and then you're trying to revoke this
the document will look huge to try to
restrict everything it's easy to just
grant one or two things and then build
up on them and one of the last things in
here uh let me just minimize this is you
can protect your assets and that's very
important what it means is uh because
you've granted permissions uh which are
minimum hopefully to a user and this
particular user doesn't have access
anywhere else with
the exception of what you're granting
them with that means that they because
they don't have permission somewhere
else it's quite likely that it's
protected because they have no access
and they have they can't believe they
can't be they can't do lots of things
which is a benefit to you and that's
exactly what we're trying to achieve so
there you go grant always this amount of
privileges possible
now manage permissions with groups
aws always encourages you to use
permissions with the groups to minimize
the workload what it means it is easy to
assign
new permissions and it's easier to
assign new permissions to a group than
assigned to many individuals users as i
said if you have a single account um
with as a group for example and then you
have a 50 100 200 users that want to use
awps guess what if someone if if you
have a change in your policy and you're
granted individual permissions to
everyone well
and you need to kind of change this well
good luck you have to do it 100 times
it's easy to basically changes on the
single group that all those users are
members rather than do it
on the individual level it is always
better and trust me after a while you
will have a mess and every single user
will have a totally different
permissions and you cannot control this
uh because you have other people that
will have access there and they will be
changing stuff so it's actually good and
the same obviously not only new
permissions but also reassign
permissions that are currently existing
which is exactly the same principle
now you can also restrict access with
further conditions and use additional
conditions such as mfa and security
groups to ensure only the intended users
can get access well that's exactly it
what you can also specify is the
basically a conditions under the policy
itself that you can say well i want my
users to have access but i want them to
use mfa for example or they're coming
from specific ips like even this and if
they are coming from these ips they can
access the production systems because
sometimes the production systems are are
very important and obviously they should
be um they shouldn't really be accessed
by everyone in your company only by the
trusted people and the ones that should
have access there and and the rule is
simple less people who have access to
something less likely is it going to
break
and that's the point so you can actually
add additional conditions like i only
want users with maybe this ip address or
maybe this api address or maybe this ip
address to be asked to be able to access
my production server and you can have
this by using conditions and i'm gonna
show you how to use it as well uh in the
few minutes monitor activity of your aws
account as we said before and quite
likely we're gonna mention this multiple
times in the future because it's really
really important is that um aws has
several features to look at user actions
uh via logs or where the cloud tray
itself and all of those for every single
users are being logged into a single s3
bucket that you can actually access and
browse through and see exactly
everything uh what is going on with your
account and which user is actually doing
uh some activity
so there you go
i have a question here from ravi babu if
web server is not able to handle
requests
if
it crosses limit and it
has to route to another server
so which user has permissions to root
the request on the server
um i would say
um
interesting concept for example in this
case if
if it's let's say a web application i
presume uh then you don't really need
any permissions uh itself because you
can access the web servers on the let's
say port 80 or for from three doesn't
really matter without any permissions
itself all you need to do is open
security group uh in between all the web
servers within a pool uh to be able to
actually be able to act to be accessed
on port 80 or 403 and in this case
it's going to be like from the internet
the web servers itself will have access
to any server on any of those ports now
this is something we usually don't do
because obviously you're trying to
restrict um across connectivity between
the servers in case one of them is
actually uh
kidnapped by hackers or something
actually happens and they can spread
between all other servers so you kind of
try to
mitigate this by not allowing anything
but on the eob to access let's say on
the port 80 itself but uh it's doable so
you wouldn't you really use permissions
because you can use just port 80 and
that's it
so i hope i answer your question here
now as we said before you have also
right to create a strong a password
policy itself
and you can actually have few things you
can specify minimum amount of uh
characters in your password which is
always a good thing you can require at
least one non-alphanumeric character as
well you can enable password exploration
and i would highly encourage you to take
as many as those sponsors as possible in
fact you know what go crazy and go for
everything there is not such a thing as
too little security nowadays and i've
seen so many times people using such a
silly password that it can be pretty
much found on the top 100 password list
available on the internet itself and
it's not very secure because suddenly
you're granting a user
ability to have a single simple password
that anyone can log in with and have
access to your entire
fleet of servers and that's scary
normally you wouldn't do this um so
there you go you have such an option so
you can
have that
also use roles for applications that run
on ec2 and that's what we said before
instead of granting users and having
keys saved on all those servers and
passwords and all the stuff which is not
very secure as we know already you can
use roles that will be pretty much the
same with exception of know you using
the password required and that's it
application will still have access
exactly where we want in this case the
application will have access to the s2
bucket but it doesn't require username
and password and that's exactly it
so
what's important and probably i don't
need to say this on aws but aws and
obviously wants you to know that is that
reduce and remove unnecessary
credentials what it means if you have a
user that is not working with you
anymore so maybe a bulb left the company
guess what remove both from uh from your
access list you don't want bob to be
still able to access all your resources
uh while he's not working that and
that's obviously it's something common
and obvious but uh funny enough lots of
people don't they i've seen companies
pretty much every single company i've
seen
has a list of users that go like three
four maybe even five years back and
there are hundreds of people on the list
that do not work anymore and what's
scary is they those accounts are active
and even something more scarier is that
some of those accounts are full admins
which means if the user that doesn't
work anymore has still full access to
production environments well it's just a
recipe for disaster and make sure that
if someone leaves the company um you
always remove the user as well as maybe
once every month or three months you do
a cleanup you go through a list of all
the users and make sure that those users
are working that and if they don't well
remove and obviously that's that's
something that we would highly encourage
i can i can see the question here uh can
we make user inactive uh kind of yes and
i'll show you how
if i can let me just remove this
because this users well i have a demo
user here and basically what i can do is
i can go to this user and you can see
that this user has
basically a simple permission
but also
you can see that the console uh sorry
i'm going to highlight this with this
and console password is enabled and
pretty much that's it there is no such a
thing as enable disable account because
there is not but you can what you can do
is basically you can disable console
access which means i will just basically
edit this and disable at this stage the
user still exists but they have no
access to the console itself but there
is a different case if for example we
generated sets of keys for the user
which i just did and just to show you
how it works
this
pair is also available and is um is it's
live well guess what the user um
it's not working there anymore so what
i'll do is i'll go to the console
password i'll maybe disable it as a
first step instead of maybe deleting
everything and also
just because i disable that doesn't mean
that user still doesn't doesn't have
access they do where the key itself
because the key is the access to the
command line despite the fact i just
disabled console console is just a web
interface that we're logging in but the
real thing is the key so what i will do
is i'll make it inactive what happens is
the key field exists but it is inactive
and why i did that
well it's a very very common situation
you have a bunch of users working in
your environment they generate
themselves at keys and they use those
keys for different things and guess what
sometimes they use their own keys to
inject in sensitive applications within
your organization and they didn't tell
anyone they just wanted to make sure it
runs and works and they they didn't and
what happens is the whole application
even sometimes in production runs off a
user key and guess what this user might
be at full admin which means the
application that is running this key has
a full admin right to entire stack of
everything you actually have which is
very bad and i've seen this every single
time and it's really really wrong and
what happens is you just
you know instead of deleting the account
you basically just make the inactive and
what happens straight away something
stopped working a system is not
responsive something failed you have
alerts coming in and instead of deleting
the key because once the key is deleted
you cannot you cannot recover it which
means it's better to disable the key
maybe wait for a week two or three or
maybe even a month and you in this case
you can be sure that nobody will be able
to use this account but if you have a
report straight away saying hey actually
our abc system stopped working and that
user was
you know he created that can you make
sure it's actually fixed you can be like
oh okay i disabled the key so maybe i
should enable the key and better yet i
will enable the key for the system to
work but i will also instead of using
this demo user i will create a special
key for this application on its own or
even use role
in order for the application to work and
i will just give it a new key name
rather than reuse the the user that is
not working with us anymore and that's
the very very common
way and very common issue where where
we've seen so many times i see a
question here when a user console
password is disabled can they ssh into
aws uh
well yes yes they can now if you think
about it um it works like this and let
me draw it for you a little bit
so basically uh there is there are three
types of access one is the console
itself and the console is using the uh
the console password so you need to use
a username and the password
to be able to access the console itself
and that's one way of doing that another
one is a
p
i an api is using a key itself and the
secret key in order to work to access
all the resources of aws and those two
methods are responsible for accessing
all the
controls of aws now if you have an ec2
ec2 server
and this server is maybe
a linux box
and it will have a keeper right well
guess what this packet keeper if is
actually sitting on top of os which
means none of that what we just disabled
is disabling the os itself as long as a
user that is for example left the
company has the keys you can even
restrict all of this away from them they
will still have access to this box
because it's like basic username and
password for the box that sits in on in
the middle of the internet so you need
to make sure that um you also rotate the
keys of the servers if you give someone
those keys um
and you clean those up and there are
multiple different ways of doing that
and i've seen that every single company
does this differently because they have
their own policies uh one of the best
ways probably to do it is divide via the
id itself which means the the the the
easy to box ec2 box that is for example
running the windows uh can authenticate
against the av server and if you remove
this particular user from id guess what
all the access to all the servers will
be invoked straight away because the
user doesn't exist cannot authenticate
with a single uh pretty much click in id
you just remove the user from everywhere
and that's easy especially when you have
a fleet of service of like 500 maybe
thousands or even even big ones like 50
000 servers guess what do you want to go
through all 50 000 servers and remove
all the user uh credentials i don't and
i'm pretty sure you don't either so
there you go
um
bob is saying that one way would be to
regenerate the key sure it would um you
could do that this way uh you could do
you know you can do this via maybe
a command that you you want to uh rotate
uh the the key on every single server
that much specific query uh you might
want to have a command via the
powershell that you want to remove the
user from there there are different ways
and there are different uh you know you
can do it in different ways it's
entirely up to you and how you worked
with before now what we will do
is we will try to go through the entire
easy to slide show um in the remaining
two hours i would say if it's okay with
you i would like to maybe extend today's
session by maybe around half an hour
because it's important for for both me
and you to go through as much as we can
through um during this today's
during today's session on the ec2
because it's a very important component
of aws so
by the time we're gonna be reaching end
of the session i will basically say this
again if everyone is okay with it
hopefully we can
um
we can squeeze as much as we can and we
can
do as much progress today
so let's begin straight into elastic
compute cloud also known as ec2
what we will learn is overview of pc2
um we'll also learn of what placement
groups are what amazon machine image is
also known as ami
what elastic localizing and auto scaling
is
instance types available for you to use
today lambda and elastic bin stock eb
ebs and efs
we'll know about aws command line
interface ebs snapshots aws recommended
best practices for ec2
instance pricing options as well as cost
associated with the ec2 itself
so i'll jump straight into it so that's
overview
basically
um amazon elastic uh compute also known
as ec2 and quite likely where you will
see ec2 more often than elastic amazon
elastic computer cloud
is a web service that provides a
resizable computer capacity in the in
the cloud that's as simple as this think
of it as as a server or as a vm or as
any other resource that you can
basically put os uh in the windows or
linux and you can basically compute uh
some applications or you can compute
something on it and that's it that's as
simple as that
um
so
elastic web scale computing
it allows you to increase or decrease
your capacity in minutes which is
exactly what we want we want to be able
to make boxes bigger with more ram with
more cpu maybe more storage and we can
also we can decrease it so if it's too
big and we want to make it smaller
because when i save money we can and
that's done with a matter of less than a
minute
we can launch thousands of servers in
the same time which means that if you
have requests uh for example to suddenly
uh be able to handle a huge sale on your
online website and you know you're gonna
have 10 times more traffic than usual
guess what you don't need to provision
weeks ahead more hardware try to deploy
this you can actually hour maybe two
before you can spin up more service
to be able to handle more traffic and
once the sale is over you can basically
decommission them and come back to
original state
it's flexible uh because you can
actually launch
different os
systems on it you can have instant types
and you can have different software just
in minutes and you can have any
combination of all of them
no matter what
it allows you to integrate integrate
with other aws products such as s3 uh
databases rds uh sqs which is uh the
queueing system as well as to provide
complete id architectural solution so it
fully integrates with everything else
aws has to offer
it is real
reliable and secure because aws operates
in a sli commitment of 99.95
of
availability what it means it's it's
pretty high and that means that at 99.95
of the time the
guarantee that the single box will be up
and running if you want those numbers to
be even higher you can actually deploy
this between multiple regions and
multiple even ac's and in this case the
whole system is almost as 99.999 and
feel kind of nice after that
also amazon provides you with the bpc
that you can create and secure uh whole
networks for all your aws ec2 instances
within
that's what we were talking about during
the dpc itself
and also it's a low low cost and aws
charges you by the hour and you only pay
for what you use rates are lower than
your existing on-premise infrastructure
that's entirely true but you need to be
careful because if you're trying to run
all those uh servers uh with the same
size that you would have on premise
and compared to the maybe on on on
premise cost quite likely the bill might
be a little bit bigger than you expect
um as you need to be smart about it and
you're gonna be discussing how to use it
and when to use it to make it cheaper
now we're gonna be talking about amazon
machine images which is also known as
ami
so what it is amazon defines lmis
an amazon
machine image also known as mi provides
the information required to launch an
instance you specify an ami when you
launch an instance and there and you can
launch as many instances from the mi as
you need
you can also launch instances from as
many different mics as you need so
basically what it is it's a copy
of your server and once you took a copy
of your server then you can basically
create as many instances from this copy
as you need you're gonna have one you're
gonna have two you can have a million it
doesn't really matter and every single
of those servers will be exactly the
same the same data the same
specification everything will be exactly
the same which actually speeds up the
deployment process if you think about it
we're gonna create a single server in
the production environment and copy the
server across every single other
environment like development staging qa
and and in this case you are sure that
everything everywhere is exactly the
same so that's a huge advantage
so um as we said mi is a virtual
instance and that includes a template
for the root volume for the instance it
uh consists a launch permissions to
control mi launch instances as well as a
blog device mapping to a specific volume
to attach the instance what it means
well uh mi is basically a
um
sorry let me go back
basically it consists the root
drive that you have always installed it
consists all of the permissions that are
required to launch that as well as any
additional um drives that you have
specified if you need it and that's
exactly what it is
it's basically a copy of every single
resource that a single server had
attached
i have a question here straight away can
we create an image from our data center
and use that
to create ami to
replicate the configuration in aws the
answer is yes yes we can what you can do
in a simple terms you can basically take
and if i presume in your data center you
might be running something like a vmware
and if you do you can basically create
and open a format a virtual file so this
is obf or ova depending on on the the vm
where you're running and that particular
file you can upload to
a aws it's a service called import
export and basically you digest it and
what aws does it takes this image and
injects its own drivers into it and then
it creates ami out of this which means
you can then basically uh launch and
server from a server image that created
on-prem and that would be quite likely
the quickest way of migrating your
workloads to aws because you can
actually have this running they now also
offer a new service called a
server migration
service that allows you to basically
integrate a connector directly with your
vmware and you can basically tick just
tick the servers and with one button it
will allow you to create a copies of
entire vm environments on the aws as a
amis and it's up to you if you want to
launch someone now so it's a fully
automated process now since basically
two weeks ago so
yes you can
now
uh
i have another question from challenges
this time
and that's a my only support image from
vmware um no the answer is no what
actually supports is as long as anything
can export to ova or vf it will be able
to digest that
and there are a bunch of converters out
there that you can use to convert
different machines
the biggest challenge quite likely at
the moment even still
is to convert a physical machines so
basically running on a full hardware
without any vm
on it into the into the cloud you will
need to use some sort of third-party
tools and aws is not doing that as yet
to be able to convert the physical
machine to the virtual one and then you
take the tool and put it on the on the
on the on the database itself so that's
pretty much the journey
so i want to mention now
and
say what is a good device storage
before i answer more questions on that i
would like to just go for this slide it
okay
uh basically there are two types of root
device storage for mics one is called
instant store and other one is called
ebs
what's the instant store is it's
basically a a place on hidden place on
s3 where you basically store uh all your
mics if you're gonna go to s2 directly
you cannot see it it's invisible to the
user it's allocated to your account but
it's only available uh through a ami
console otherwise you cannot see it and
what other type is is basically amazon
elastic block storage which is basically
a network drive so if you had a server
let's say in here that was
created um the server itself had os
which quite nicely sits on the s3 as a
part of the root device and any
additional drive that was attached to
this particular server sits on ebs as a
snapshot and that's simple as this
so every single ami sits on both s3 and
ebs depending how many drives you have
attached and that's basically how it
works
um
i see
[Music]
i see here a question from uh haddish
okay that's great how about a windows or
linux server which has the db or web
application installed can prepare an
image to do that um yes you can i would
say there are advantages or
disadvantages of disadvantages of doing
lift and shift so basically taking
whatever is on prem and migrating this
onto the cloud uh it's basically a
pretty slow process can be um but also
it's not cleaning process what i would
advise as as a as a good
gesture of advice from from the
experience is that most of the time when
you want to migrate stuff to the cloud
it's sometimes uh quicker and easier to
basically deploy from the scribe so
basically launch the server and just
install application then start uh and
try to migrate lots of things from your
own print the reason is if
if you have old systems and i've seen
this quite a few times they do not
integrate well sometimes with the cloud
because they were not designed for the
cloud and in this case uh it's easy to
create a new system install everything
on you and have it clean rather than
migrate in some cases it's impossible
because the systems that you have and
people that work on those uh do not work
anymore hence you have no expertise how
to redo it again in which case litter
might be the only way you can do so you
need to convert those into the uh the
vmware
uh ova uh files and then ingest that
directly into the aws and try to launch
that so not always it would be 100
working sometimes windows or linux is
always running on the old core old
version and it throws some sort of
errors i've seen this in the past quite
a few times recently i see it less and
less because most of the modern systems
are kind of cloud aware so it's not a
problem but with the very old systems
sometimes i still see it so there you go
um
um i see lots of questions here which is
good um
how am i instance will identify ebs
storage does it have any connectivity
framework to the identified ebs solid
itself yes ami itself is basically a a
copy of
of of
an instance itself and it has a
reference to ebs from the snapshot so
when you create a new server uh let's
say you want to create a new box from
ami what it will do it will basically
pull all the data from instance on s3 as
well as take a snapshot
and take this from the snapshot and
restore as a drive so suddenly you will
have a server with a root device and eds
in exactly the same fashion so mi is
basically a configuration file with the
image on s3 and snapshot on the ebs
that's all it is
i will be able to answer more questions
at the end because we're gonna uh get
stuck on the slide 13 i will never
finish this session so um i know you
have lots of questions and i'm more than
happy to answer but if we have enough
time at the end so i do apologize for
all of them
now instant store root device uh for the
instance is an instant store volume
created from a template stored in s3 as
i mentioned before so basically instance
store
is exactly the um
the the the place on the s3 that you
store all your all those images and this
is where you store your data from the
device and that's it as simple as that
now uh amazon ebs
the the root device for the instance is
also it is an amazon ebs volume created
from ebs snapshot it can and how it
works is for example if you had your ami
so let's let's imagine situation you had
your server
that a root device was actually
a
abs volume so it was e b s
which means when you snapshot it the ebs
volume itself got snapshot
got
had a snapshot created on the uh abs
itself and now when you restore it it is
a
root volume which means it was not
necessarily stored on the s3 but it was
stored on the eps as a snapshot itself
so you have a different scenario here
and that's pretty much it so
itself really explanatory
okay i can see a question here of what's
the difference between instance store
and ebs
okay what is the difference is uh
all types of
servers running in aws had and instances
also uh had instances running on
so-called a root device that was not a
dbs what ebs is is basically a network
drive so imagine that you have a server
and this particular server can run from
two different devices one is called uh
ephemeral another one is called eps so
let me just e b s and this is uh
fmro so just to explain what a female
drive is is the drive that's attached
basically to the underlying host so to
the server itself and what happens is if
you have an ec2 instance
and
you shut it down
what happens in this case is you lose
all the storage assigned to this so
basically you lose instance you once the
server is off you just lost it all the
data was persistent on it the the reason
aws did that is this this was one of the
first infrastructure uh
attempts and that was very popular
around seven years ago and for around
five years or six years now ebs is
taking over in fact 99.99 of service
running right now are ebs only which
means even if the server dies the ebs is
still persistent which means all the
data is still there which means you can
stop the server start the server you can
basically create copies of it and that's
it so the difference between your
question now is is that the old
fashioned and ephemeral store was
actually stored on s3 now ebs itself is
is stored on the ebs volume
as a snapshot and that's the difference
so i hope i answered your question
um
and exactly here we quietly gonna see
some differences
in this particular chart so
we have amazon ebs backed volume and
also amazon instance stored
backed
so how it works is the difference is
boot time itself is usually less than
one minute and if you ever launching
this through a store box it's usually
less than five minutes so it's much much
slower why well because the s3 will be
slower to restore all this data because
there is a bottleneck of of a single
connectivity while ebs is basically
restoring a star which is much quicker
size limit uh ebs can be 16 terabytes
and an instance store back can be 10
gigabytes so you can see the advantage
of eps there again a root device a
volume it can be amazon ebs volume and
in this case it's called instance source
volume so
it's different names and
um different capacity also the most
important thing that i'm going to
mention at the bottom and then i'm going
to go through other few things is that
it can be placed in the stop state when
the instance is not running but the
volume root volume is persistent in a
ebs now the difference between ebs and
non-ebs is cannot be stopped uh in the
stop state instances are running or
terminated as i said if you stop an
instance with the amazon instant store
backup which means you lose all the data
and quite likely you don't want to do
that the good news is 99.99
of the servers right now are running on
the ebs in fact uh every single time
you're trying to spin up a new server
via
ami or anything else it default function
or different option is an evs you can
still spin up all type instances if you
really want to but nobody does that so
um
the news is if you spin up the server
it's almost 100 it's an ebs so you have
no problem with that so basically that's
it
that's the explanation between those two
so another type we have is the hvm
versus pv what it is and why
do we
care now
a pv stands for power wheel drives and h
vm
stands for hardware mutual machine
what it is is a it's an amazon um
way of basically creating ami images and
keeping this in their own
environment in a visualization
environment what it is is uh pve uh was
the old generation
of virtualization that was dependent
more on the software so software was
assigning lots of um
resources was basically software driven
allocating cpu processes and all the
stuff and it was uh it i wouldn't say it
was slow but it was a little bit uh
dependent on software and has those the
bottleneck and then aws came up with the
hvm which is a hardware virtual machine
which means the type of the machine that
has access directly to the hardware is
actually running which if
you think about it if you can skip all
this software on top of that and you
have access to all the hardware that you
really should it's much much quicker and
in reality it is much quicker and the
difference is in here when you're
launching a sometimes servers in the
brackets you will have either pv or hvm
again 99 of the time you're gonna have a
hdm because that's a default behavior
now because aw wants to give you the
most um up-to-date and the quickest
performance ever hence you have this
so most of the time you will see hvm
out of the box
so as i was saying
um
all the
all the all the ebs volumes are stored
under the ec2 dashboard in the elastic
block store
basically
section of the page and in order to
access this you basically go to the
volumes and you can see here that you
can create a volume and what it is is
basically a network drive that you can
attach and provision so if you
create one you can mess the conclusion
by yourself i will show you this a
little bit later during today's session
because we will be talking about that so
yes it's here and we'll be discussing
this
um
so
coming back to the slide
i'm sorry it was this one
so
uh choose mmi and
the first step of launching any new
instance is selecting ami so you before
you even start you will need to create
some first server and to do that
obviously you cannot put any cds or
floppy disks or anything else to
basically install your os you need to
have something already
running in order to to access that and i
would highly encourage you to use aws um
amazon linux in the linux section
because it's probably one of the best
and cleanest builds i have ever seen and
it's also probably one of the most
secured because aws takes security
really really seriously and allows you
to have extremely clean and yet secured
built over linux itself but also they
allow you to spin up windows boxes
obviously in this case we have a windows
server 2012 but they also released
recently 2016 that you can access and
pretty much that's it you can see as
well i'm going to show you here that
they do specify this is the http that we
just discussed um which means that uh
it's a hardware machine which means it's
extremely quick as well as they specify
ssd volume type which means it's an eps
backed uh machine you don't you see
there are no machines in here that
specify
the
internal uh root volumes because it's
not really used anymore because having
servers is off and losing all the data
it's not really
called server would be called a suicide
in my case so uh there you go i showed
you that let's skip straight into
uh
amazon linux is also supported and
maintain uh linux image provided by ws
as i mentioned uh this before and i
would highly encourage you to use this
because it's a very good starting point
and
aws is taking full responsibility to
update this very very often you can see
basically build new builds of the same
updated box every week or two and then
with this new ami and every single time
there is some sort of security thread or
or some sort of uh you know announcement
they always punch those boxes straight
away which means if you launch a new
instance from this new ami well guess
what if you have up-to-date most modern
box without doing anything you just
basically launched click the button and
you have already security covered um
it allows you to uh have repository
access to my sql postgres robby duncan
and all of the things as a default by
linux it's regularly updated as i
just mentioned and it's also
pre-configured with the tools to access
amazon cli api and other ami tools which
fully integrates with your aws account
which is awesome you don't need to do
anything just put it and you have full
access to everything on aws obviously if
you granted permissions
so
going forward
we also have something called aws
marketplace uh it's basically an online
store uh where you can buy um a software
that runs on aws from either aws itself
or a third-party
providers and quite likely if i'm going
to show you this in a second you will
quite likely recognize lots of them you
have a trend micro you have logic pretty
much any company out there right now
that is big enough to to to to be known
is already on the marketplace you can
have any solution that they're providing
you're going to have a trend micro deep
security for example you can have an
under
other logic log manager um you know
anything you can think of it's probably
there so you don't even need to build it
you just buy the solution out of out
from from them and you can see the
pricing models for example um in here
you can see that they uh for example
trade trend micro uh security uh costs
you anywhere sorry uh that was a little
bit too thick let me just make this a
little bit smaller
you can see that they're charging you
somewhere from one
dollar fifty per hour uh
or eight thousand six hundred seventy
four yeah for the whole server if you
think about it and depending obviously
what it is it might be cheaper to go on
the passive role model then start buying
licenses up front because you don't
maybe want to use um
you know a specific solution for more
than a few months and you don't need to
pay up front so that's why you will use
that or you may even want to try the
solution before you even buy it so in
this case you can subscribe or to pay
per hour use it for maybe two or three
days and then once you're done you just
basically terminate the instance and you
don't pay anymore you try it you use all
the features you know what it is you
know if it's good for you and if it's
not terminate and that's it so there you
go
um
i have another question here from
charanjit if we need to custom if we
need customized package which we need to
update in amazon linux is there such a
provision with aws um i would say like
this the most common scenario and
situation is as follows what you would
do in this case you can
let me go back to a few slides you can
spin up a new server from aws itself so
basically amazon linux server itself and
you have ami id here don't worry about
this id this id changes every uh week or
so so it's always different but if you
click select it's always choosing the
most recent one once you have the server
running which is a pure aws uh linux
itself then you customize this uh
server to your liking so install
anything you want on it and install
anything secure it make sure it's got
pretty much everything you can think of
and once you customize this box what you
do after is basically you combine to
create a
and i out of this which basically if you
think about it what happened is you had
a mi here
then you span it out into the ec2
and then you created mi again out of it
what it gives you is ability to take
this stock mi customize it whatever you
want and export this to mi so then when
you launch it again
ec2 you have a fully custom
uh
server that you have just created
secured updated and did whatever you
wanted and you can spin up multiple of
those so that would be the journey most
of the time
um unless you don't want to use
their mics and you want to upload your
own
mi from your own environment then you
can so yes
so let's get straight into the
marketplace we did
and then we also have so-called
community mis there are a bunch of other
people out there very smart people that
really work hard and and and they are
very passionate about the database
itself and they want to contribute they
create different systems they create
ready servers for you in order so you
can just launch it and play around with
it and you can actually see it in in the
console itself you can basically choose
os you can choose anything they created
a full let's say blown telephone systems
like uh asterix they created um
everything every system out there if you
think about it quite like it really
exists uh in the community mis because
people already created it um
um
so
there you go i have another question
from target who will have the
responsibility for patching amazon and
linux aws
uh is it aws or or or or you no it's a
good question uh before you speed it up
um before you take the mi from aws it's
their responsibility to
uh patch their own ami of their own
linux and they constantly do this every
two weeks they have a new version of
security and all these things once you
launch this into your environment it is
your responsibility from this moment
onwards to keep it up to date aws will
not come to you and update your system
because they have no access to it as we
mentioned on the session number one so
once you launch this from them it's your
responsibility now if you take this
instance as we mentioned before you
create your own ami
it is still your responsibility because
it's your own am i now it is your custom
data so i hope um
i hope i i answered this
um
which means we need to buy support from
amazon for applying patches um
um
no
actually uh most of the time what we do
is we manage our own service rather than
amazon does this for us in fact amazon
doesn't have access for data
you can manage all those servers by
yourself and that's the whole point once
once you
customize anything from aws or launched
anything it is now in your hands in your
layer of responsibility because it's
your data they don't have access to it
anymore they own the hardware underneath
they own all the network and security
but everything that sits on os and all
the customization that you just done it
is your own responsibility
um
um can i have an another question from
rabbi bubble can we connect
to party using ap
that is generated
um
i believe that in the
in the next few uh slides we will
actually have
that
accidental and how we connect to it
i have another question here from
chandra if i need three instances of
trend micro instances uh
do i need to buy three times from aws
marketplace uh yes in in this case if
you need uh three instances that are uh
for any reason um i think maybe what
what what what you what your solution
here could be is you can buy one trend
micro server that acts as a security box
and then you're gonna install agents on
the remaining boxes that connect to the
trend micro server for all the scanning
and all the security maybe that would be
a better way of doing so you have some
sort of electron micro server and as a
management console and then you install
just a small um
basically
demons or or or clients on each other of
your systems
i can see another question here is
oracle enterprise linux supported on a
aws ec2 uh it's a very good question
andre i
honestly uh don't know
i think the list of of all the supported
oss is pretty long because the versions
as well
have different um
options there i think out of the box
oracle itself um is not because i never
ever have seen oracle enterprise linux
out there but i could be wrong so i
would say check the commentation to have
correct answer to this question so i'm
sorry i cannot answer that
so
now you can as i said already you can
have a standard mi that was deployed by
aws and then you can customize ami to
your liking and save it and we'll be
showing you how to do this
so creating an mi use an existing emi
launch instance customize it and create
a new ami from it and finally launch
your instance as
a server so this is exactly what we said
so you have a ami that is basically aws
mi
uh sorry for that again big font let me
remove this
a
ws and then you launch that and then
basically have an ec2 running here
and then you once you customize this and
did everything you wanted you then
created
your own imi which is a custom
and then once you have this if you treat
this as a golden image then you can spin
up any amount of ec2 systems out of it
and then you can have multiple of them
anywhere else so what how how we would
do this and why we would do this
is
we would most of the time create a
custom golden image for all of our
systems and servers and basically every
single system and server that we
launched in the future would be exactly
from this build here because we know
it's stable we know it's security
patched we know pretty much everything
about it and we know also that no matter
how many times we're going to speed it
up and how many copies we will create it
is always the same which means you only
pass the system once and then you launch
it and it's exactly um the same copy
everywhere
in fact what lots of people do instead
of actually once you have let's say
twenty hundred thousand servers running
instead of actually updating all of
those servers individually right so
jumping on those boxes and running maybe
update update update update what they do
is basically i take this ami
that they create a golden image they
launch it
uh basically they go all the way to the
step one so launch the golden ami update
it again go through all entire process
again and create a golden image version
two and then what they can do is they
can slowly start killing those boxes and
replace them with the version two box
itself it's much easier when you have
multiple a few hundred servers let's say
to update image once and make sure it's
fully signed by security it's fully
passed it's fully up to date rather than
do this hundreds or thousands of times
and it can be achieved basically by
doing one
box once
um
so there you go
so sorry about that
sorry there you go
also what we need to mention today is
that ami can be distributed it can be
either private
um it can be kept private
it can be
shared between
a different account that you specify or
if you want you can even publish this
into aws marketplace and other people
can use it so you can have let's say you
have a good idea or you're very good
with linux or windows and you have some
sort of idea for the system you deploy
the system you convert this into the mi
and basically you publish this as a mi
uh marketplace and people can now use it
either for free if it's open source if
you wanted to to make it like that or
you can specify that you want people to
pay you for it for every hour they use
it and there are quite a lot of small
developers and small system application
owners that actually have good
applications and they basically allow
other people to launch their own systems
and they trust them per hour so you
don't have to spend all this money up
front and it's easy
to all the consumers so you have option
of doing so
i can see a question from charlie in a
free trial can we launch more than one
ami
um
i would say
yes you can
but the specification states that you
have 740 hours of a free
ec2 running
per month which means 740 hours converts
to a whole month of a one t2 micro
instance running so imagine maybe i want
to have two instances running but in
this case i would need to have two t2
micros running for half of the time to
in order to have this for free or if you
want you can have 740 instances running
for one hour in the same time
to have this free so that's what aws
states
now
uh we created ami and what we want to do
is basically we wanna remove it because
we don't no longer need it uh so with
the process of removing the mine we call
the registering
the ami itself
what it means is
when you register mi you
basically remove all the data that links
eba snapshot and is into instance itself
which means that the ebs snapshot will
still remain in here but uh you delete
any record of the copy of it which means
you have no way of recreating this
instance anymore yes you have a server
running as here but once the server goes
down you cannot create any more copies
because you deleted a basic main copy
that you created all those servers from
so the process is called the registering
and um okay let me make it smaller it's
again getting excited this pen
um so this is this is it once you
deleted the ami you cannot remove it
well if you created maybe some sort of
resource from ami like this you can
maybe take the server later on and
convert it to mi again
and that would be the way of restoring
it but there is no other way of
restoring the individual mi or the
registered ami
next one
now also
what is important to mention um
okay i have requests from chandra
regarding can i repeat it again
sure
when we created mis uh basically what mi
is is a collection of data and
configuration that allows us to create a
new service from it which consists of
ebs snapshots and also consists of other
ebs volumes that are allocated to this
in order to for us to create easy to
instance so basically that it's a copy
of a server that we can uh launch
multiple times so if you want to delete
it we basically did register uh the mi
which means we remove all the
configuration
from uh from from our from our
configuration here and that means that
the snapshot itself um
uh will remain
easy to instantly was actually running
from it will remain and then what
happens is we can delete the snapshot
itself that was used for the ami and in
this case we will have only ec2 that was
created from it which means that
deleting mi does not delete any servers
that we created it's not it's actually
keeping them alive it's fully
independent so that's what i meant
before
um
i have another question from chandra aws
will
will daily take the snapshot of the
emails volume uh by default they don't
it's entirely up to you how you're gonna
do this you can actually have a simple
script running saying i want to
basically take a snapshot of all my
ebs's which is actually a very good idea
and it's a very good backup strategy for
lots of people so by default aws doesn't
do this but you can enable
this as a function and make sure it is
running
so
another thing that is
very important to mention is uh is tags
and i really want to stress this out
target instances to allow easy
identification and management of the aws
resources and as i said before imagine
you have an environment that you have
maybe 100 200 maybe 500 servers running
and you
basically all those servers are probably
members of some sort of application
group or some sort of system and you
have multiple systems well guess what if
you do not tag them it's going to be
difficult for you to know of what server
belongs to where and even what is it for
so using tags will allow you to easily
um uh identify which server is part of
which system and easily navigate between
someone in the did resources when you
create or change you will not make a
mistake
uh you can create your own key and your
own values you're gonna allocate for
example i want a key to be something
like a system and the value to be maybe
web system
or
key to be system and the value would be
a database
or anything else you can allocate key as
a for example owner like
owner and then equals and you can
have maybe maybe charges owner of the
server so you can easily identify who to
contact in case there's a problem in the
system and you have full freedom to time
all those systems and with any values
you want there's no restriction limit on
that you can create as many times as you
want and it will be you'll be able to
easily determine uh
that also another benefit and biggest
advantage of times that i have seen in
the recent uh probably year or so is
that imagine the situation that you are
running in a big organization like
multi-level company and they have
hundreds of systems running and guess
what each system is despite the fact
it's working for the same company they
maybe have a smaller subsections of the
companies and each subsection is paying
for their own system so they have
basically internal billing for all the
systems they're using it's very common
and what would happen is database itself
will only give you a master bill for
everything running on your account will
not split it out and you think wait a
minute but i i want my bill to be you
know detailed maybe per system i i don't
want a master deal because i don't know
how much i should build people and yes
you can kind of calculate that but it's
going to be extremely difficult and this
will never be accurate so what you would
do is you basically create a tag
that you can call anything you want i
would say maybe create a type called
system equals to a name of the system
let's say dr or or or a part of the
company or something that can identify
that and all of those systems can be
fully independent with their own tags so
if we have a system here that we call
maybe a a test and then we have another
system that we call production you can
then generate the bill based on the tags
and you can see that a system that with
the tag
test costs let's say one thousand
dollars while the production costs maybe
two thousand dollars and that will be
breakdown on your bill which is easier
for you to build um either your company
or maybe your clients because running
account for multiple clients of yours
so tiles are very very important and
it's very um easy to implement but
without it it's extremely difficult i
can assure you of that
so what we will do now it will
demonstrate how to launch uh
an instance and connect to it and we're
gonna be connecting to easy to instance
itself
so let's start some fun i will see if i
can maybe launch instance
on
simply learn
console
obviously expired
uh
one second
i will basically log out from mine
i will see if i have permissions to do
that so let me basically log out from
here
let me login
in here my courses
enemies architects
projects
glove access
aws
okay if we're gonna go to easy2
i think we should have some sort of rice
to create something
okay we do
i hope we do i don't see any errors here
which is good so what we need to do is
let me just see uh demonstrate how to
launch and connect to the ec2
instance itself so we have zero running
instances so what we can do is we can go
to
uh either instances and you can see
pretty much nothing on this
uh and we can click on launch instance
when we do that um we have on the left
side we have navigation my amis
obviously we have none
um
we have marketplace that i mentioned to
you before you have a bunch of different
systems and quietly there are hundreds
of thousands different systems here so
you can maybe search by by the by the
name and you also have committee mis and
you can see people created a few things
like
english for containers and they have
maybe full sql server and they have uh
um
anything you probably think of already
existing here so what we're going to do
is go to quick start and in the quick
start we're going to launch amazon and
linux mi that we mentioned that's
running on the hpm which is the hardware
visualization and also it's running us
on the ssd and that's the ami that we're
going to be spinning this from you can
see that this instance is only available
in 64-bit which means 32 is not
available um so make sure that your
application can support it and what we
can do is you can see here that we're
going to launch the ip2 micro because
it's a printer
for us and you can see that it's
specified in fact it's not 740 hours in
750 hours it was which was my mistake
and you can use this for
for the for for for your testing so
let's basically uh
uh basically next
and
um
oh awesome
i have no permissions to list any item
roles contact administrators so
um
okay i don't need that
in order to launch that
uh let me see let me see we need for
instance uh only minute one
uh it's not the export instance which
i'm gonna explain in a second um the vpc
that we wanted to i'm gonna launch it in
default uh subnet we don't have any
preference
uh assign auto a public ap i would say
enable and the reason why is if you do
not enable this you cannot connect with
the instance obviously
shutdown behavior is stopped and pretty
much everything else is a stock i'm not
gonna touch any of those values here
now it's gonna ask you about the root
volume which you can see
is basically
a a
uh eight gigs of size and it is a
general purpose ssd i'm going to explain
all those in a second i'm just going to
basically leave everything as it is by
default
i'm going to give it a name i'm going to
give it the demo
uh ec2
and what we will do is we will enable
ssh and what i will do personally i will
basically enable this to only be able to
access my internal ip um
so i'm gonna select existing security
group as well
uh that's a default okay so let's create
a new group in this case i'm gonna call
it i'm not sure if i have a right demo
security group
now let's try and see what the system
will say
okay i didn't complain so far that's a
basically breakdown of everything in
here
and if i click launch it will ask me for
a keeper because i don't have any
keepers
allocated with this instance i'll
basically create a new one and i'll call
it a demo
key pair
and i'll download this for the
gatekeeper
and basically i will launch the instance
and that's it the instance is launching
you can see if you're gonna click on
this link you can see that we are
currently spinning a brand new linux
server it's a t2 micro that we chose it
it was allocated to us east 1b because
we chose random instance state is
pending because it's still uh basically
initially initiating um
and it's using a demo key
pair that we just
defined and you can see when it was
launched uh here and you can see
security groups you can see much more uh
breakdown about this particular server
here you can see all the devices
connected to it network interfaces
pretty much anything you can think of
and one of the things that you also see
is the ip address which is a public ap
address that we just generated and
that's that's that's actually a good
thing so
let me see if i have any questions no
which is good at this stage don't worry
um and that's it we just spun out a
brand new instance that is currently uh
running quite likely still initializing
which means that it's probably still uh
launching it can take the process itself
can take anywhere between maybe a minute
to maybe five depending how big the
instance is and how much complexity it
is to uh to process it obviously if you
created a huge ami out uh
instance uh and saved custom one with
loads of data on it and i mean like
maybe two or three hundred gigabytes of
data it might take maybe five minutes
maybe ten minutes to boot because it's a
huge amount of data to process but the
empty ones like this usually do not take
too long and once it's fully running
i'll be able to connect it and i will
show you how to do it so let's let's
leave it uh
running there fully to be fully set up
and once it's done we'll basically
connect to it
and now we're gonna do the same for a
windows server with exception i'm gonna
actually spin one
why not we can do this we're gonna
launch the instance and you can see uh
lower at the bottom we have a windows
server we have a server 16 we have a
server 16 with the base nano we have a
bunch of other ones i will not connect
to the 2016 yet because uh i still
prefer 2012 um so what i'm gonna do is
i'm gonna launch a standard i'm gonna
choose 2d micro as well because it is on
the threader as well
i will basically just one default no
preference
assignment ap i will enable this and
basically nothing else as standard
the default
server on the windows is actually using
30 gigs not eight and the reason is the
windows out of the box is probably about
20 gigs um just windows itself that way
it's much bigger so we're not gonna
change any details here
we're gonna call it uh
demo
windows
ec2 uh sorry ec2
continue
we will choose a new security group uh
we will call it
demo windows
sg
and to connect to the windows we need to
use rdp to do that which is obviously
0.3389
i'm going to only allow for my ip
address um let me just copy this
let me view
that's a breakdown of the windows itself
obviously a keeper and i'm gonna show
you what's different between linux and
windows so basically we can reuse the
same keeper as we just downloaded
because now we have one uh if you would
have more created you would have a whole
list here and that's not for the user
that's for the whole account which means
if any other user creates any keys
you'll be able to see it on the list
here
uh i we need to acknowledge now that you
have access to this key otherwise
obviously you cannot access the server
and basically launch it and with a
matter of seconds oh no
we have some sort of error which quite
likely means we have no permission to
something to do that and i need to again
a contact simply to grant us the
permissions to to do that uh i'll be
able to spin up a new instance and maybe
on my own account later on if you want
windows um let me
uh let me now create an ami so what i'm
going to do
is i'm going to go back to the
to the console
let me see if i have any
questions someone's got exactly the same
error uh it's uh
um as
high as the same error as as i do uh yes
it's because probably we don't have
enough permissions to to
initiate some resource
which obviously that particular error
message is not very
uh you know it's not very helpful but
funny enough if you take this error
message and paste this in a support
ticket for aws they will be able to
decode it and tell you exactly what is
wrong so if you ever have a problem that
you don't understand
contact aws support give them the copy
and paste from the screen
and they'll be able straight away to
tell you hey actually you don't have
this particular permission um so that's
a clue for you and a big big um help
so if i'm gonna go back to the console
itself and go to dc2
what i will do
is i will basically download party
uh we use party basically to connect to
the
linux servers and module view um where
is the download here
party
tell yes
yes please and also we need the packing
chain and i'm gonna explain why
patty itself is a
a windows
application that allows you to connect
to linux systems by the ssh and some of
you might know it somehow you might not
so what i will do is basically i will
minimize this window i will minimize
this right now
and i'll go to my downloads
downloads and i'll basically launch
party so we have a battery running here
but because we downloaded the uh the key
which is in the pen format and but it
doesn't actually um allow you to use
spam you need to use ppk format what we
need to do is we need to convert this
key
i will need to load this as
administrator
starting my application might
run anyway
let me put my top secret password here
and there you go what we will do is
basically drag we cannot we're gonna
load existing private key so uh
downloads
and
basically
sorry i need to go to
system
users
simply lag
downloads and then what we need to do is
all files
demo
open
successfully imported and now what we're
going to do is we're going to save a
public
uh
deposit the public always private
i think it's a private
and we don't want to pass phrase
i usually want to say yes
and then basically we can call it a demo
kb
and you can see that extension itself
will be ppk
save
and you can see that we just generated a
new key uh in order to access that if
you will be using any other system like
even linux you don't have to do this and
the only reason i have to is because i
use windows itself and to connect from
windows to linux i need to use uh
unfortunately party which is which is
one of the simplest forms are out there
so what we can do right now is we can go
to our instance that we just spun up
it's here you can see running instances
we can see one demo ec2 which is
obviously in linux it's fully running so
what we will do is basically we will
copy the ap address which is public
and we will
place this
in
putty
there you go so what we will do after
that is we need to basically uh
uh load the key into it to do that we
will go to the ssh
and
it's in the connection i believe where
was this data
are you okay in the username we're gonna
specify pc2 dash user
and then we also need to load a key
which uh as far as i remember
is
here in the text section
uh sorry i need to specify the house
name
um
session
sorry not the other authentication my
mistake again so i will load the demo
pbk key
open
and under session now i can basically
call it as a
demo
pc2
i'm gonna save this
and let's see if we can actually launch
it
okay we can see pretty much nothing in
the screen which quite likely means that
we have no access to the box uh from
security perspective or maybe there is
no internet connectivity so let's maybe
dig into it and see why
so we can see that this instance is
running in the subnet which is the
default one uh in the default dpc so
let's go to the vpc and see why
potentially we don't have access in
there
maybe it's permissions again
so our bbc's default one
okay pretty much everything is in let's
see the root table for that
roots you can see
uh
there is
um
a zero zero zero slash zero enabled and
it's going to return a gateway but you
can see the status here is a black hole
which means maybe just maybe someone
just needed internet gateway
uh itself
so let's go to the internet gateways i'm
gonna open this new tab
yep the gateway doesn't exist so what we
need to do is well guess what it
probably uh
because everyone has access here
a default
internet
gate
way
and i'm going to create that
we just created a demo internet gateway
in here and what we will do
uh sorry default internet gateway and
what we will do is basically attach this
to the vpc so we go to the default one
attach it
and boom it's attached so we're going to
go to the root table again
the one that is in our vpc for default
um it's this and then a root table
and this book table
and roots we can now change this entry
to
the default gateway
and then save
and hopefully
it's active which means
with a little bit of luck
we'll be able to access this instance so
let's try
again so let me go to party again
basically we load the configuration and
open
well we have some sort of notification
it actually says do you wanna uh agree
to the fingerprint guess what i do
and just like that we just end up on the
ec2 instance and we are now
authenticated on top of the linux os
itself so we can do any command we want
something like
maybe ping
the maybe
google.com
and with this you can see that the
instance itself because we just granted
this
access to the
internet gateway which was deleted by
someone maybe by mistake
allows us to actually pin outside world
and obviously this this particular
google server will see us as the uh
elastic ip that we assigned during the
process of creating ec2 which is exactly
here
that's the one
so there you go
how do you access a windows instance
that's actually a very good question i
can actually show you uh this and how
you access this i will need to log out
from my own account and log into the
uh
sorry log out from this one and log into
my personal in order to show you that
basically what we will use is we will
use the same keeper but because windows
doesn't accept keepers what you use the
keyboard for is to create to decrypt
username the password and i'm going to
show you how to do it so let me log out
from here
okay i just did that's great let me look
in myself
that's great i'm gonna go to ec2
let me just see my running instance in
which vpc it is usb pc one eb at the end
which is fine i'm gonna launch new
instance
i'm gonna launch the instance in the
ssr2012
i'm gonna use this as a free tier again
just because we can
a number of business one
i'm gonna launch it in the
web server vpc
uh i it's my basically something that i
created before and i want to assign
public
ip to it
and no other changes i want to make in
here
as again 30 gigs we're not gonna change
it
we're gonna call it demo
where
demo
windows ec2
next
we're going to create a new rule
rdp we're going to call it a demo
windows security group
i'm going to copy the same thing in here
in the description
i'm going to connect for my own ip
breakdown which is exactly what we want
and basically because i don't have any
of those keepers
on this computer i'll create a new one
i'll call it demo
windows
key
i'll download it
and i will launch the instance quite
likely i do have a right on this
particular account to do so so we're
gonna wait few seconds for this to run
there you go we see green window which
is always good to see
um
and the instance is now pending what we
will do is we'll wait for this instance
to finish speeding up the windows itself
can take a little bit longer and i mean
maybe 20 30 longer because obviously
it's windows is heavier bigger and even
the storage wise it's probably double
triple size of what linux is running so
what i will do is i will
log out from this account let it spin up
and i'll sign into the simply learn
account
unless our session expired or again
sorry about that jumping bigger accounts
is not easy
so log out
login
sign in
my courses
this
love access
there you go we are on the correct
account right now
and in ec2 what we will do
is we will basically
create an ami
so imagine we are on this box that we
collected before on into the amazon
linux on the simple account and we made
a change right so let's say we want to
see where uh what what what what what we
have here um
basically as as default you're always
going to end up in the ec2 user account
when you're looking at the box so if
you're going to go inside and obviously
not all of you might know linux inside
out which is absolutely fine what we get
we'll do we'll list all these folders
and files in here we have nothing
which means nothing there
if you want to customize the box we can
for example create a
uh test
dot txt
and type here
hello world
uh i'm gonna save this
and right now it's gonna list we have a
single file that we have created in the
basically our user directory called test
and if you're gonna copy that file which
means display
we have text hello world and i know it
might not be the match but exactly what
you have is customization in the box now
you can do anything to it you want you
want to create maybe folder structure
you want to install applications you
want to run updates think of
of anything you can do to the os itself
either windows or linux fully customize
it to make it ready and once it's done
what i would recommend to do is
basically before you take a snapshot
which is very recommended is to stop the
instance so basically shut it down
reason why is because when you create a
snapshot and a lot of data changes aws
cannot guarantee consistency of your
snapshot because everything is changing
all the time so a part of the hard drive
that is being snapshot which is a
physical uh replication drive and will
consist some data and some other data
that was overwritten after the whole
whole process would be lost so it's
recommended to basically shut down the
instance so what i'm gonna do is
basically uh
actually in this case power off and you
can i need to get root
so power off
and what happened just now we just shut
down the instance and the instance
that we just logged on
on this account you can see here it's in
the stopping state which means it's now
gracefully shutting down we did it from
ios level which means we pretty much
doing everything uh in the graceful mode
which means it's kind of trying to close
the program so it cannot go behind
especially in windows
linux will actually be a little bit more
um brutal with that but make sure you
save every every single thing you you
ever wanted and also before you create
mi make sure that you clean it up which
means that all those uh installer
installers that you downloaded to
install application all the
configuration bus everything that you
have
you actually remove because when you
spin up this whole new box you don't
want the mask to be there as quick as
possible is always the best so now you
see the insides in the stop state which
is great so what we will do is create mi
how do we do this well you can click
right button on it and in the options
here you have instant state so you're
gonna start the box stop the box we
booked the box even terminate i don't
really want to do that because i want to
create um am i out of this in the
settings here so you can settings you
have other remove tags you have instance
types so basically change what kind of
instance it is you have change
termination and a few others but the one
that is actually interesting to us is
under image we want to create image so
what we do is we create a register call
and then we have a
simple form of image name and
description so let's say i want this
name to and the name to be demo
uh ec2
ami and then you can put something like
a v
uh zero one so we know it's a version
one an image description you can put
whatever you want i will basically copy
this
and worth actually mentioning that you
could put in the description maybe a
date when the image was created so you
have some sort of reference
and pretty much that's it and it will
have exactly the same details so you
don't change anything unless you want
the snapshot to have more storage for
some reason and then you click create
what happened is create image creation
is requested and it will
be
now created so if you go to the amish
you can see now in under mi that there
is little cog here spinning on the
screen uh in this place which means it's
processing you can see the status is
pending you can see that when it's
initiated uh and basically what it is so
it will give you all the information
possible also
it doesn't really indicate indicate how
long it takes so sometimes it's quick
sometimes it's slow depending on how
much the game you have just because this
instance was basically empty box it
should be pretty straightforward and
quick and
as a part of this you can see also under
the snapshots
that um
basically
here the snapshot is being completed is
exactly the snapshot that we just
created
under the ami
now that's just being registered and
should take more or less five minutes uh
in order to to be become available once
it is you can then spin up the server
and if you do launch the server from mi
that we just created guess what if
you're gonna go to obviously the party
once one or a command line you will
start the server you will see the file
that we created because all the changes
are exactly there so all the
customization we've done is already
embedded into this box which is a great
news so uh on that uh there you go it's
available straight away i could launch
this instance and show you that i'm not
sure if i want to because it's just
pointless we'll have to wait for
additional five minutes and i prefer to
go through um
um
through the same process again i cannot
show you exactly what we uh created in
the in the demo a few seconds ago um i
have a question here and what is t2
micro large or small i will challenge it
i will answer this question in the next
few slides because we'll be going
through different types of instances uh
maybe more security maybe memory maybe
storage and maybe even sizes and i will
show you amazing websites that you can
actually see all the breakdowns and how
to actually choose appropriate size
instance to your system and so
um i did the demo here i did the
material that's good now instance types
exactly what i did ask about uh maybe
three minutes ago
what the what are the instance types
and why we have different instance types
so
uh it provides a wide selection of
instance types optimized to fit at
different users cases and that's
important
comprising varying combinations of cpu
memory storage and networking and you'll
be able to choose different types for
different situations
give the flexibility to choose an
appropriate
number of resources for application also
include one or more instant size to
scale resources to required over target
workloads remember when we discussed
that aws is fully scalable it can grow
vertically and horizontally and choosing
appropriate instant size is treated as
actually growing um
vertically which means making size
bigger you can have a small box you can
have a medium box and you can have a
large box bigger the box is more
resources you get allocated and that's
and that's vertical uh horizontal
scaling is if you have the same box and
you make more of those uh but you can
have a hybrid of those two you can have
a situation that you you want maybe two
medium boxes uh four small and one large
why not it's entirely up to you its
imagination is your limitation
so uh what do we have is
in uh we have a general purpose um
instance type in fact uh probably 99 of
the time i use only those three and the
reason why is most of the applications
that i worked and my clients ever worked
uh do not require specific required
requirements for gpu or maybe for
storage or maybe and maybe of other
things and and i'm going to come back to
this in a second
and i'm going to explain what it is and
why we use it so we have a general
purpose um
it's basically in the general purpose we
have a t2
m3 and m4 and those instances are kind
of um
very very
generic they have a good combination of
memory cpu and everything is pretty much
balanced they have more or less equal
amounts of cpu versus memory versus
pretty much network so it's a little bit
of everything um and it's pretty much
good for everything it's like universal
um instance but then
we have uh instances in the compute uh
optimized called c3 and c4 and what that
is is a little bit of trade so imagine
you have application that is extremely
cpu intensive performs lots of cpu tasks
and i've seen this a lot of times and
you don't really need memory that much
because application basically crunches
through the data and basically
processing everything can so what you
can do is you can basically uh have a
little bit less memory and have more cpu
which will actually make your
application happier and quicker so you
would actually go for c four or c three
instance types and
basically it's used for uh cpu density
databases web servers applications etc
and that's a very good uh place to be
so if i'm gonna now go to memory
optimize i can show you this
it's a r3 uh instance type uh it is
basically used for memory intensive
databases web servers and applications
the ones that require lots of memory an
example here i can give you let's say a
caching server is a very good or even a
database that is running with maybe some
sort of memory cache that you you want
to use and you don't want to access the
hard drive all the time you want to
cache as many things as you can in the
memory to have as quick responses as
possible so you might want to go for r3
what it means is you will trade a little
bit of a cpu and you you will trade a
little bit of of of of a storage so you
have a little bit less of those
resources but you have much more memory
which means you can utilize this to a
full potential of the application and
it's entirely up to you how you're going
to use it but it's
important to remember that you have such
options in which case you can allocate
exactly instance that you need that is
tailored towards your application to
make it the most efficient not only cost
wise bios and performance wise
now we have a fourth time of uh
of of instances here uh called also as
g2 what it is is um is basically an
instance with a dedicated gpu which is a
graphic card which is uh used for a lot
of 3d applications for machine learning
video encoding and lots of other things
um and if you have such application that
you need to run on aws you quietly will
use that because you will use all the
power of gpu which is probably around
anywhere between thousand and even ten
thousand thousand times more powerful
for specific applications uh to process
data through gpu rather than cpu and
that's exactly what we would like to do
um
i have a question here from otis if i
have a map application would it make
sense to use the gpu format uh
refresh i would say like this
i would start maybe with the cpu uh so
c4 or maybe
general purpose see how that works and
then see if the application that you run
uh support is supported by the gpu here
basically what they run is nvidia kepler
um
cuda course and you need to make sure
the application can utilize those via
the opengl on it itself and before you
even spin it up so i would say for
testing purposes feel free uh but not
all the applications are running so make
sure they do
and one of the last uh types we have is
basically storage optimized uh family
type which means it's less cpu less
memory but it is actually loads and
super quick storage and it's used for
and non-simple databases hydro and also
data warehousing where the d2 is
actually used for file system data
warehousing and other things like hadoop
which means if you need loads and lots
of iops on the drive so you have lots of
read write and all those operations well
yes you quite like you will can use any
of them but the biggest advantage you
will get if you're gonna use optimize
like d2 because you're gonna have so
much power and so much network um that
you're not gonna have a bottle like that
and that's as i said most of the time
what people do is they launch the
general purpose they see what the
bottleneck is and once they detected it
and know what the problem is then they
allocate correct instance to it so don't
don't don't think that you you are stuck
with it you're not play around with it
see what is the most efficient for from
cost perspective also from uh from
performance and then choose appropriate
so there you go
and one of the last options it's not
really a
instance type but it's an option for all
of them is basically ebs optimized
what it is it's a little thick box when
you spin up any of them of those that
allows you to accelerate your net
network between your ebs so basically
your data store and your uh server
itself if you don't think that you'll be
pretty much running on the standard um
speed of the network which is most of
the time okay but imagine you suddenly
have a database and a bunch of web
servers and the last thing you want to
do is for the database to have extremely
slow connection to the network drive
that you store in the whole database in
it and you don't want to have a
bottleneck there so what you would do is
you would basically take eps volume tick
and
you allocate more ios which i'm going to
show you later on how to do it as well
and you'll be able to guarantee that the
performance of the hard drive uh of the
this is ec2 ec2 sorry for my drawing
this is a e
e
s so the performance between those two
is as
as as good as possible so the latency is
the lowest and you can have hundreds of
thousands of operations flying around
this single wire between those two if
this is slow because you didn't think it
uh well guess what you'll be limited and
the bottleneck will be so big that you
might have a problem with it with the
transfers transfers and performance
above certain stage you might not notice
at first but when you have a spikes you
will quickly notice it
so
um
yes now we're gonna demonstrate uh
different instance types
uh for
uh uh in aws
so i'm still uh on the
simply learn account i was still waiting
for my windows to boot uh quite well he
already did but i want to just go on
with this and one of the last things i'm
going to show you is how to print
windows at the end of the session so
what we will do is basically we'll try
to have a different instance type so
what we do is we go to instances and we
basically launch instance
we choose a random one uh from the list
because i
you know i i don't really care this kind
state and there it is we have these
different instance types you can have
here from the drop down you can have a
micro instances general compute gpu and
memory and storage um
and also you can have a generation you
can have alteration or current
generation what it is is
as i mentioned before there is something
like a c3 and c4 c4 is the latest
generation so it's using the latest
hardware and c3 is the previous
generation of hardware that they had
if you think about it uh which one you
should use and why funny enough
the latest generation always and this is
always the case is not only cheaper by
around maybe five to ten percent that
equal size server
with the previous generation but also
it's much more performance about 10 to
20 depending which means why would you
ever want to go to c3 if you can have c4
so the latest one and you can have not
only cheaper server 10 but also more
performant and i would say
never ever go for c3 because you
actually pay more money for less
performance you always want to be on the
latest hardware so always go for the
latest one you can there are situations
that you have to use c3 maybe
i don't know maybe rest of your
application is already on the c3 and you
need to just add one server and you
don't really want to add c4 because you
don't want to mix the performance levels
within the whole group
maybe that's one of the situations so
maybe you have such an old old
applications i have never met them but
it's possible that doesn't actually work
on the latest uh intel processors for
some reason um
and you might wanna you know go to all
c3 or m3 or anything you want so there
you go the list of the of the instances
is pretty much long and you have a
different types and i'm gonna actually
show you a few things now
i'm gonna highlight here uh for you guys
so you can see the instance that we spun
up was basically
a
general purpose instance and it was t2
micro which had one cpu and one link of
memory it's not much uh for the demo
purposes is probably more than we need
for what we've done so basically create
a single file with hello world that was
okay
for production environments maybe not so
so you have different sizes you have a
micro you have a small you have a medium
you have a large you have extra large
and so forth and they go pretty much
in incremental of times two and you can
see that c2 small for example compared
to t2 micro has the same amount of cpu
but it has two years of memory suddenly
so you double the performance uh of the
of the of the instance itself you can
actually ask well you really didn't
double because you still have one core
but you have two gigs of memory yes it's
true and maybe from performance point of
view you didn't really double it but in
the size as iws gives you you did and
next one small to medium you actually
double everything is two to two cpus and
then you have four gigs of memory and
the same applies to large sudden you
have two but then you have eight gigs of
memory so memory went down but if you
went you know pretty much the same so
bigger you go uh more resources you have
and
also more expensive you get and i can
show you a an interesting website which
i will send you hopefully
in a second if you're gonna type in
google aws ec2
types
uh basically the website that i use a
lot is called ec2 instances dot info i
like this website because it's key it's
basically one sheet
of of the data on a single page and i
can choose lots of things it's not aws
uh website itself it's a third party
someone created this website because
they were so passionate about it which
congratulations is very very good and
you basically compare instances here and
regarding cost as well and you can have
let's say we just spun up t2
micro instance i can highlight that you
can see it's got
one gig of memory and it's got one cpu
and you can see that again instance
costs us on the linux on demand here
cost us 0.012 cents u.s sense that's
important to remember an hour
well if i want to spin up a bigger one
just because i need more power like uh
maybe too small i'm gonna get two gigs
of memory let's do one cpu i'm actually
gonna pay double for it
and pretty much the cost always doubles
as far as you you go and you have
obviously different instance types you
have
like that was the two medium we have m4
large for example in here and this gives
you eight gigs of memory also gives you
uh two visuals if you use but what is
actually important here it gives you six
and a half units of processing power
called ecu and i'll highlight this for
you right now
so basically we're talking about this
column here
and what it is what is a compute unit
aws defines a computer unit as an equal
measure to a more or less one gigahertz
of cpu itself
so in this case we can say in this
particular server has more or less six
and a half gigahertz of processing power
which means with the two cpus we can say
it's 3.2 gigahertz each core
and that's pretty much what it is this
particular box has 13 gigs of of of
pressing power uh and obviously four
cores and the numbers go bigger trust me
uh you can see that you have instances
that um especially the let me just call
it a bit down if i can you have
instances that will allow you to have
maybe up to
349 gigahertz of power which gives you
up to 128 cpus and of course it's
immense number yeah but also the price
you have to pay it's around 13.3 dollars
every hour you use it well
obviously more resources you buy from
aws more you have to pay per hour but
quicker you do it so if you have maybe
application that requires processing
power and you know we want to spend a
week or two to do it maybe it's worth
launching a bigger instance like
something like this to process
everything much much quicker and save
time but you know the cost might be
exactly the same as you would run the
same application for a week of the
smaller instance and maybe you're gonna
finish in the day the cost might be the
exactly the same
but you save yourself a week which means
it's a huge saving in time
so uh you know make sure you you
understand that
um let me just see if we have any
questions let me actually copy this uh
page and i'll paste this in for you guys
here and um
i'm gonna send it to all
there you go i hope you have this on the
chat
feel free to play around with this
website uh you can basically um filter
by memory maybe you want to say i want
to aim to piece of memory inside of me
only instances available here for you
will actually be uh
memory uh minion two and maybe you wanna
say you know what i want an instance
that is minimum two gigs of memory i
really want this to be cheap what you
can do is you can order this by the cost
and suddenly you can see that the
instance that comes straight away in
here cost wise is is t2 small which
gives you exactly two gigs of memory and
is the cheapest because you just ordered
this by price
and there you go you can do this the
same by the cpu maybe you need to know
how many cpus you have
basically and also make sure that you
choose appropriate region reason why is
lots of servers within different regions
will have different prices i'm going to
show you this straight away so i'm going
to remove this and i'm going to order
this by the by the
name let's say 82 small and we have
titles more highlighted and that's
currently the cost of the titus mall in
london it's zero
0.026 cents an hour
now let's change it to maybe a mumbai
and you're going to see that you have
zero points
30 cents per hour it's 4 cents a u.s
cents more expensive you think why well
maybe running cost in the
buy is much more expensive like cooling
cost and and electricity and all this
stuff but if you're gonna go to let's
say no north virginia suddenly the cost
goes to zero zero 53 which is the
cheapest why because that's one of the
first data centers they created and they
have a huge amount of service there
that's why the cost is the lowest so
it's entirely up to you how you're gonna
do that
and and there you go that's pretty much
what we have in this particular slide uh
different types i just um
showed you uh and
uh what i will do is i will try to
commit maybe extra
20 to 30 minutes to go through as much
as we can before christmas guys for for
you before the whole break uh so you can
have lots of information i hope this is
all okay with you and
and uh if if it's not okay with someone
please let me know we can maybe stop
here
but um obviously i'm i'm kind of doing
this outside of the time and i really
want you to know as much as i can and i
want you to have all the knowledge and
all the examples so let me know if
someone is um not okay i think everyone
is pretty much okay i see all the
answers yes yes yes yes please okay
great so i will continue
so
aws elastic block store storage
everyone is always happy to learn more
that's very good to hear uh turn to it
um so
what is elastic block storage um
it's basically
a storage that provides persistent block
level storage volumes to use with with
amazon
instances that's all it is if you think
about it it can be something like a
iscsi it's a basically network
attached drive that you have access on
the block level which means you can have
access to every single block of it
and that's it that's pretty much
explanation and we could go into much
more detail but to be honest it's boring
and it's not needed that's all aws ask
you to know
um
i have a question here from uh ravish uh
there is something also called elastic
bean stock yes there is and we're gonna
get to this uh in a second in one of the
um
one of the slides as well i hope you're
gonna manage today
um
so uh we have
um basically like this
um
oh my goodness again
pretty very happy
again a block
level storage used to create a storage
volumes and attach them to ec2 instances
you use them in multiple cases
you use them as file systems databases
or any other block storage in this case
you can attach it to the to the instance
and you can treat it as a hard drive
that's all it is
you place them in specific
azs which is enveloped with this zone
and
they are automatically replicated you
back them up as a snapshots as we will
pretty much demonstrate and they are
designed to have a 99.999
availability which is quite a lot if you
think about it so basically they are
kind of bulletproof uh i don't even know
a single hard drive manufacturer out
there they can actually guarantee more
than 99.9 i think seven percent of
uptime which means that the drive quite
like will fail within three years for a
few minutes um and and you know it's
amazing number 19.9.999 it's it's a huge
number so
let's try to jump into the next slide so
we're going to discuss more and there
are two storage categories uh basically
there is a ssd backup storage type
and here and there is also hd backed up
storage type
why why there are two well guess what we
are living in the new world that ssd so
solid state drives um are taking over
they are so quick they are so light and
so energy efficient that it would be
almost a crime not to use it and you
have all the benefits of extremely quick
performance you have extremely huge uh
throughput through um to access the data
and extremely quick responses like
almost a minute like nanoseconds almost
it's extremely quick now hdd is an old
magnetic type with all those spinning
plates and all of them unfortunately uh
there are still good they still use but
they are kind of slow and
if you can have ssd um which kind of is
always guaranteed by default now to all
those instances why would you ever want
to go for hdd and yes hd might be a
little bit cheaper and it might give you
um a little bit
a little bit more storage but
to be honest for the amount of uh
gigabytes or even tablets you can spin
up you quite likely never notice the
difference in price and ssd will quite
likely be around 100 times quicker at
least
so
you know we can we can we can see
different types now ssd itself
allows you to have a provision iops and
also general purpose and there is a
difference between them
when we use it and why
basically we use provision iops
in io intensive nosql and relations
databases so when we use it is every
single time you need to guarantee that
your application must have the quickest
possible uh access and what provision
ios is is basically dedicated io
operations um a second so they give you
this in a in in in the number uh
maximum is 20 000 uh
per single volume which means you can
have 20 000 read and write operations
every single second on your volume um
obviously in case you use 16kb uh as a
as a partition size and they give you
amazing throughput of 320 megabytes per
second yes it's not megabits it's
megabytes per second that's yeah that's
insane and also uh the price
is kind of a medium it's kind of it's
you know it's not the highest it's not
it's not the cheapest but it's kind of
acceptable and you use it if you need
lots of performance now when you use
general one i would say use general one
pretty much for everything you can and
that's my recommendation i would kind of
stay away from hsd not because
i'm not recommending this but i used it
a lot and since i started using ssds
during general purpose
i fell in love with it i think the
performance is so awesome the latency
access is so quick and the price is low
to medium which means it's not really
that pricey and you get amazing speeds
and there are limitations you can only
have between one and 16 one gig and 16
terabytes of volume to which most of you
16 terabytes is pretty much
you you will never use that and imagine
that's only one hard drive you're gonna
have multiple of those connected to one
instance you're gonna have
if you can have 20 if you want which
means it's insane uh yes it's a little
bit less uh performance but to be honest
when was the last time you use 10 000 or
iops on the daily basis on all these
applications and systems we maybe use
between 300 and maybe 500 maybe pushing
for very busy systems sometimes when
you're running
very you know intensive
tasks like maybe computational databases
maybe you reach like two or three
thousand ten i've never seen in my life
yes you have a little bit less
performance uh some uh transfers but
it's probably one of the most common
ones i'm going to start here
now going back to the hdd you do have a
type of the hdd that is basically a um
and it's called st1 which is used for
big data and big warehousing and what it
is is basically a collection of hard
drives in a raid array that they give
you basically a big storage of up to 16
terabytes and they give you only funny
enough about 500 maximum iops which is
not designed for for obviously all those
extremely quick applications but what is
designed for is basically storing data
for for a long time and the cost is
basically low and medium but what is
good is the transfer that you can get
out of this which means if you need to
process huge amounts of data but you
don't really need iops that you would go
for that and the same for the cold and
magnetic now those are the old ones and
you can see that performance here is is
is kind of lower and lower and you get a
really low amount of iops and
basically cost is low and then cost is
lowest is the cheapest out of all of
them
i would say most of the time i would go
for a general purpose more storage you
allocate more iot guaranteed and as
simple as this so that's that's the
point of this slide
um i have a question here from target
how much they read throughput and right
throughput which one is higher in both
storages i would say um i would say
it's always
higher uh in ssd um that's that's the
truth i know that you have a value of
500 here but there is one part you can
see that you only have 500 uh read and
write operations in case you use a
volume uh
basically partition size of one meg
every single time
but guess what when was the actually
last time you actually had exactly one
big files most of the time we work with
the files that are super tiny like
kilobits and in this case this
performance you would never need because
you need one make partition in order to
do that in this case i would always use
either of those because they give you
the most performance and once you
actually start downloading all those
tiny files this 500 goes maybe down to
50 if you're lucky because the io will
be your bottleneck which means this one
will be much quicker long term so i
would say usually you use the general
purpose which is probably the best
combination of um of the of the of the
storage you can have and if you have a
very sensitive
latency based um applications like a
databases or anything else use the
dedicated one if you run out of here i
would always start with this one and if
you have any problems then switch to
this one and that's basically the truth
so what i will do is i will go to the
eps encryption now dps
allows you to um encrypt all the data
and what it means is you can take ebs
and you can basically encrypt it with
your own key and that what we call is
encryption and rest which means all the
data stored on the ebs
can be fully encrypted and the key can
be kept on the uh on this on the aws
system called kms and you can have your
own key created and you can pretty much
encrypt everything on the aws itself
maybe you need to do this for regulation
purposes maybe you have some sort of top
secret information
to be honest there is a little bit of
overhead of decryption and encryption
it's all hardware i have to mention this
um
and
performance regulations may be around
five percent so it's not that great
uh not that big number so don't worry
you're not gonna have half of speed but
you need to remember that obviously more
encryption you you use then more
overhead it will be sometimes you must
and there is no way of using something
else
and
i have another question here from um
from actually two questions i'm trying
to do if in the database read request is
high then is it good idea to use ssd and
where a write is needed can we use
magnetic storage um i would say like
this
that all depends on the database itself
if your queries are massive and
basically uh there are linkedin between
multiple tables and everything else if
you think about it all of those are
actually hundreds and thousands of very
small requests with different indexes
and different um tables and everything
else which means the request is too
small but you need lots of iops in this
case i would always use ssd
and i would not really recommend
hdv backed ebs volumes for any databases
uh and that's the truth um
whenever you think database always think
ssd and the price difference between
those two is not much but you're gonna
thank me later that the performance of
ssd is at least 10 20 30 times more on
the aws than uh of the hdd itself
so there you go now
we have another thing called elastic
file system and what it is and when do
we use it well elastic file system is
basically a file storage service for a
amazon elastic cloud compute
instance what it is and why do we want
to use it think of it as basically a
network um
server
basically it's a storage on aws that
allows all your instances to save data
and use this data as a um
as a storage um and that's it it's
basically like a a network folder that
you can down all the files and you can
connect multiple systems too um i would
not recommend using this as a primary
source of of all all the os uh all the
os files what i would use it maybe for
is to keep it as a central point for all
your configurations or your systems
maybe the data that all the systems are
using
and you can attach all of those
instances to it and once they're
attached you can basically read and
write and change whatever you want and
that's it that's as simple as that
so i'm going to show you how to attach
dbs volume and
on the demo right now
if i may
so we're going to go to the
uh the instance here
uh let's hope the session didn't expire
did it
no it didn't that's good
okay i can oh my goodness someone
deleted our instance
it was deleted by itself after some time
actually no it's still here so what i'll
do
is
it's in the stop state that's why it
didn't show in the in the dashboard so
zero running instances
um so i'm gonna go here
um and i'm gonna go over uh we have this
instance here
uh i see a question from uh uh
harry what is the difference between efs
and ebs it's a good question ebs is the
hard drive it's a network hard drive
that you attach directly into the server
itself and server can access this hard
drive on the i o level so basically
imagine that you just plugged in a usb
hard drive to your laptop
and you can access this hard drive like
that now efs is a network uh drive it's
a basic network storage like a folder
um and you basically access the data
there so
think of it as your maybe nas box or
maybe your
windows file server box you have access
to the folder itself but you don't have
access to the whole hard drive which
means you cannot perform specific
operations like you cannot format it
because you have no access to the block
level you can access files but you
cannot do anything else with this file
with this with the system so that's the
difference
so how do we create the volumes and how
we attach it so in here in section under
the elastic block store store basically
if we expand it we go to volumes and
what we do is we have one volume running
which is exactly the one that was
created automatically before uh when we
expand up the instance and here we have
different uh
basically instance types what i'm going
to do is i'm going to choose general
purpose
and size of it i'm going to choose maybe
50 gigs
and you can see straight away that this
number here number of iops
is actually changing so if i choose 100
suddenly changed to 300 why why why did
it happen is because for every single
game for general purpose you get three
dedicated operations um that you have so
if i choose 10
we will have
100 because that's a minimum number but
if i choose let's say 100
we will get 300 and the same if i'm
gonna add additional zero we're gonna go
all the way to three thousand and that's
the biggest you can pretty much um have
i'm gonna choose let's say 50 gigs just
because we can we have 150 uh dedicated
ios and the important bit and you have
to remember that the important bit is to
always choose correct um availability
zone if you don't do that you will not
be able to attach this particular
storage to the instance so what we do is
we basically look here
um
i will need to close this unfortunately
because i didn't
uh sorry no i can see it sorry you can
see
um
let me just close it
so the instance of this panel is running
in the u.s east 1b and that's important
so when we create a volume
let me do it quickly again
uh 50
we need to make sure that the volume is
exactly in the same region
because the volume cannot be attached in
a separate regions so we choose 1b
we don't want any snapshot and we we we
don't want encryption right now because
quite activate this we don't have
permission to do that
so if we create one
it's gonna basically provision brand new
and let me refresh this
there you go we just spun up uh or
allocated a brand new volume that is 50
gigs it's a general purpose storage 150
ios and we can see the date when it was
created and we also see that is in the
az-1b and what we just did is just
provision 50 games of storage well
that's great
what you can see here is the storage
straight away straight away uh available
if you're gonna choose a bigger storage
something like maybe one terabyte even
16 terabytes quite likely you'll have to
wait maybe for a few minutes because in
allocating all of this storage might
take some time and resources for aws but
small storage like 50 should be
available straight away so what we do
well guess what what we can do is
basically action and either this way or
we can click right button on it and
basically attach volume we have options
like ddit create snapshots and other
things but we want to attach it
because just because we created the
volume doesn't mean we attach it to any
server so what we do is we attach it we
have only one server running on this
account uh which is a
demo ec2 which is in the stop state
which is fine with me doesn't really
matter
and then
that will be the path that is create uh
attached as under linux and on the
windows obviously it's gonna be a little
bit different so if you attach this
great i have no permissions to do that
absolutely great
sorry about that i i was not aware about
that but what would happen if i would
attach this it would basically
be attached and linux itself would see
this volume straight away and you'll be
able to format it and you'll be able to
uh start
writing and reading data from it and
that's pretty much it uh so that's as
simple as this
you can see here that you have a cold
acd
and you have
also called sc1 and you have a
throughput optimized hdd
what it is is called hcd is
is used to store data but the throughput
itself is not
um great which means it's used to store
long-term data for code purposes so it's
not
as needed instantly as possible but you
want to store as much as possible the
basically the throughput optimized hdd
which also is known as st1 is the one
that doesn't store as much data but the
network traffic that is basically from
the storage to your instance is insane
and this allows you to copy data faster
obviously st1 quite likely sold the
throughput optimize is much more
expensive because network is probably
much more expensive than the storage
itself especially using normal magnetic
drives
but
um
that's the difference and if you want to
store the long term storage you would
use code if you want to have quick
access to your data you would use st1 so
that's
that's the difference
so there you go
i would say like this
i'm um one of the last things i want to
do
is i want to show as i promised so i'm
going to log in from this particular
window
and i'm going to log into my own account
and i'm gonna show you accessing uh
windows boxes as quite a few
requests that i was unable to do due to
permissions uh issue
so if i'm gonna do easy to use on my own
account have two servers running i have
a demo
a windows ec2 uh there you go and i have
my test website that i was playing with
and i can see my instance
is running on display ip yeah that's
great so i will see if i can access this
so
what i'll need to do in order to access
idp i'll need to make sure that i
know username and the password right so
if i'm gonna do remote desktop
connection
and i take my uh server ip that i just
copied from the public ap and try to
connect it will ask me for my
credentials well what are my credentials
i i don't have them right
all i have is a basic demo windows
windowskp.com which is basically
encrypted key so how do i do that well
in windows what you do you can click
right button
and basically you have option here get
windows password and what you do you
basically it will say i need the demo
windows kp that i the key itself that i
i i span of this box with so all you
need to do is basically choose
demo windows kp open that
that will be basically encrypted key and
once you uploaded that you can decrypt
the password and suddenly you see that
you have a server here with the ip
address administrator and the password
which means the credentials for this box
when it's spun up are actually sitting
on aws
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
copy that
i'm going to switch to my remote desktop
i'm going to type administrator here
uh administrator
and i'm going to copy my password and
what we might see oh i think i mistyped
something
more choices i think i mistyped the
username
that looks better
i cannot even spell
there you go what happens is now it will
say hey are you sure you want to connect
to this box well yeah i kind of do
so
what happened
is we have a black screen which is fine
windows is loading the desktop
now
the windows we chose is a t2 micro box
which is extremely small so might be at
first a little bit slow when in setting
up the profile once this is done which
might take a few seconds
so no worries it actually will happen
eventually as you see um
and we are on the box basically and it
will go into the
profile itself and you'll be able to see
the desktop
and that was as simple as this so the
difference between linux and let me
minimize this and let it run in the
background 100 is ready so the
difference between linux and and windows
is that in linux you don't have this
option uh because it's not a windows box
you will need to use the key to generate
it and in windows because windows
doesn't use this key you will need to
get uh windows password and that's how
you're accessing it so i hope i answered
your question it's still doing something
come on come on i want to see the
desktop
come on windows
you can do it
let's wait few seconds here for it
okay
so
basically
what we just did
um
my part doesn't want to hide
two bars
settings
height that's where they go boom
as you see suddenly we are on the on the
windows box you can see here from the
logo we're running windows 2012 r2 in
here in theory once if i have correct uh
resolution you'll be able to see all the
hostname and everything that aws are
allocated you can see to micro let me
just draw it for you sorry you can see
that instance type is set into micro
it's uh you know
eu quest 1c you can see private ap
address you can see public ap address
and you can see also i instance id as
well as the host
and
basically it's just a windows server you
can do anything you want with it you
want to ask the internet well guess what
you can and
you'll be able to do that
let me wait for
ah
okay
i see that enhanced security is enabled
so to disable that need to go to the
server
manager
not that i would encourage you to do
that in the production systems but just
for the purpose of that in the local
server
in here
advanced
it's on i'll disable this off off
okay
i'll minimize this i will close that and
i need to reopen that again
otherwise we won't be able to see many
websites and you will have to click
multiple times like i agree i agree
agree
so come on windows you see because the
instance is a little bit small 82 micro
with only one core and and one gig of
memory it's it's a little bit slow and
and i wouldn't really recommend running
t2 micro for production windows boxes
because it's not really performance and
boom we have internet straight away we
can access the internet we can download
applications and you can do other things
and if we're going to go for
task manager there you go you can see
pretty much dust manager all the
performance
of the box you can see that we are using
about 20 of cpu pretty much doing
absolutely nothing on this box
we use 0.9 gig of memories of 90 and we
don't even have anything running on this
box which is purely windows doing
something and
we have users basically one user um and
we can see that this user is using um
internet exploits using six percent
which doesn't actually nothing happens
on this website is already using 20
almost sometimes percent of cpu which
means obviously the box is a little bit
small for production environments but
for the testing purposes it's more than
you need so there you go
so thank you so much for today and see
you soon
you